you can watch all previous afterwords
programs on our website book tv.org
and now on book TV were live with author
and investigative journalist annie
jacobson his Jacobson is the author of
four books including area 51 the
Pentagon's brain and the newly released
phenomena the secret history of the US
government's investigations into
extrasensory perception and
psychokinesis any Jacobson live on in
depth for the next three hours starts
now
Annie Jacobsen let's start with some
definitions what is area 51 area 51 is
that secret base out in Nevada where all
kinds of mysterious things happen that
you and I can talk about and maybe we
know what's going on out there maybe we
don't why is it called area 51 big
debate I believe it's called area 51
because of the original project that
went on out there in 1951 information
given to me by some of the sources that
I interviewed at length for that war
that book but of course everything about
area 51 is kind of a puzzle inside of a
puzzle so that's even debated the actual
origins the original date the origin
story of area 51 so 1951 what was going
on the Atomic Energy Commission was
doing lots of nuclear testing out there
in the middle of the desert and they
wanted to you know keep what they were
doing secret and the CIA was kind of
coming into existence with its programs
and the two merged in this idea of if
you have a secret base inside of a
secret place you can do secret programs
so this was not a military operation
necessarily well area 51 has every
organization you can imagine there over
the decades
military intelligence community Atomic
Energy Commission so everybody has their
foot in area 51 I think what is
Operation Paperclip what was Operation
Paperclip well so I get the ideas of my
books from the books I've written before
and when I was finishing up area 51 I
learned quite a bit about some Nazi
scientists who were here working on
programs and I found this fascinating in
particular a fellow by the name of
Siegfried Kanaya Meyer okay now Kanaya
Meyer was a very important Air Force
technical intelligence person and when
he retired in the 70s he was given
the Defense Department's distinguished
civilian service award so that's kind of
this incredibly high honor to get from
the Pentagon and when I looked into his
past I learned that he had been harmed
during the war during World War two he
had been one of the most important
technical intelligence officers for
Hermann Goering of the Luftwaffe and he
was given the highest award that you
could be given there and I thought how
does this happen how do you work for one
side and then work for the other side
and that is why I wrote Operation
Paperclip that was the springboard of
that of that journey into that you know
narrative story but what was Operation
Paperclip it was to bring Nazi
scientists to the u.s. correct yes after
the war we brought as many as 1600 Nazi
scientists to create our weapons
programs and you know this is something
that really is brings up a lot of moral
questions and what I what I found most
intriguing about writing that book as a
journalist
perhaps with all my books is trying to
maintain this neutral position and
looking at both sides of the argument
because you know many people will tell
you paperclip was imperative we have to
bring those Nazi scientists of the
United States in order to beat back the
Russians others will tell you how could
we have possibly brought these you know
Nazis here some of them were war
criminals there's you know DoD weapons
policy for you in a nutshell ie
extremely complicated and always you
know two sides of the argument
what is the Pentagon's brain
the Pentagon's brain book number three
for me okay so that idea came from
paperclip when my editor I was finishing
up with paperclip and Wernher von Braun
is probably the most famous Operation
Paperclip scientist created our rocket
program and then you know really
responsible for the Apollo program in
many
and he was a Nazi scientist he had been
Hitler's rocket builder v2 s yes yes and
my editor at little brown asked me when
I was finishing up paperclip what did
what went on with von Braun in
such-and-such a year and I looked into
it and found out that this was in 1957
that this new agency was emerging at the
Pentagon and it was called ARPA the
Advanced Research Projects Agency we now
know it is DARPA with a D for defense
but when they were beginning this
organization you know the query was
which who's the best scientist in
America to lead this program to lead all
of American you know military technology
in in bloop was called blue sky research
and they chose von Braun and they you
know he was interviewed for the job but
his caveat to take the job was yes I'll
take it but I need to bring 12 of my
colleagues from the rocket program and
they were all former Nazis so kind of
that was the dividing line for the
Pentagon they said no and they passed on
von braun being DARPA sector and you
know but the but the way that it came
about of calling at the Pentagon's brain
was really realizing that the Defense
Department is looking at the great minds
that's what they're concerned with they
want to know who will lead us in
technology of the future what are some
of the things that have come out of
DARPA I mean you name it I mean the most
famous is of course the Internet which
was originally called the ARPANET but
technology is like GPS laser weapons you
know there's no end to what the Pentagon
produces you there there's reason to say
that artificial intelligence is a DARPA
product biotechnology so there is the
the idea that the pennant this is
important to think about DARPA is the
most powerful and most productive
military science agency in the world
and so few people know about it that's
pretty much why I wrote the book in a
nutshell because it was like how can
this agency be so significant kind of
changing and shaping our world if you
will and yet it's it's you know it's
public perception is close to zero
psychokinesis what is it Annie Jacobson
book number four for me that I have that
just published last week is the idea of
well the book is called phenomena and
it's about the government's
investigations into extrasensory
perception and psychokinesis
extrasensory perception gaining
knowledge through means other than the
five nonsenses psychokinesis the alleged
ability to move matter with the mind
these are very controversial subjects
and subjects that many scientists will
tell you is pseudoscience why I was
super interested in writing about this
was having come off of this very hard
science book the pentagon's brain on the
other side of the spectrum was what's
sometimes called squishy science but the
Pentagon the Defense Department the
intelligence community they are
interested in both of these subjects and
so so am I so taxpayer dollars are spent
studying psychokinesis and ESP yes yes I
mean this goes back by the way look all
roads leads back to the Nazis I find
certainly when I'm investigating and
reporting on Defense Department weapons
programs and intelligence community
intelligence collection programs and ESP
psychokinesis this whole idea of the
phenomena leads back to the Nazis as
well so the we're talking decades of
research in this area still going on
today but the original programs came
from the idea that after the war we had
a intelligence collection unit called
Operation Alsace it actually began you
know in the end
when the war was still going on and we
sent our sort of finest scientists to
try and capture Nazi technology and we
did and this is the link between all of
my books so one of the cache of
documents that we found this links up to
the book phenomena is was part of
Heinrich Himmler's science organization
organization which was called das on an
air Bay and within that organization
Himmler was investigating extrasensory
perception psychokinesis map dowsing and
when we got these documents they became
very interesting to a lot of individuals
in the military intelligence community
particularly because guess who got the
other half of the documents the Russians
so anything that we knew they had as
well
we were worried about who would win the
race and that is how the psychic arms
race really began same way the you know
over in the hard science department you
had the the rocket arms race that idea
of getting man into space began with
captured Nazi documents v2 's and
scientists literally von braun was your
career art to be a historian talking
about national security affairs not at
all I mean fate and circumstance kind of
intervene in one's own life I think
that's why it's such an interesting
concept for me to write about about how
you know circumstance has a role in the
path that one one is on I wanted to be a
novelist when I was younger and I went
away to boarding school with a
typewriter when I was 15 and I was going
to be the great American novelist and
you know decades passed and that was not
the case and I am one of my mentor said
to me stop making things up
pursue the truth it's the truth that
matters she also pointed out that I had
a little difficulty following direction
and that if I worked with an editor
at a newspaper or a magazine I would you
know learn how to follow direction and
that was exactly what I did it was
extraordinarily helpful for me and I
tell anyone who's interested in you know
having struggling with writing to do
that because if you have if you're
willing to take criticism about your
work and work with very smart
individuals who can help you
you know streamline your ideas and pull
out what's really important and send you
on other paths and suggest you interview
different people that becomes I think in
an enormous leap our phildee
when you bring other great minds into
the mix to kind of direct you and then
you kind of wind up where you're headed
at least that's my experience
well Annie Jacobson how'd you get
started on area 51 well that was fate
and circumstance intervening ia I also
think luck comes into play you know and
what was interesting writing the book on
extrasensory perception and
psychokinesis is a lot of a lot of the
scientists who leaned toward let's say
the supernatural talk about luck and
they talk about coincidence and they say
these are these these fall into that
category believe it or not of
extrasensory perception that's kind of
intuition it's a very squishy science
concept to think about but I like
thinking about it particularly because
of this question that you brought up so
how does one get a lucky break okay you
could say fortune favors the prepared
mind if you're always you know reading
and writing and thinking and working on
subjects that are of interest to you
then circumstance intervenes and you are
on your way but specifically with area
51 I was at a dinner party with seated
next to a gentleman named Edie Lovick
who I had known for five six seven eight
nine years he was sort of a distant
family member always under the
impression that he was an aircraft
designer because I knew he worked for
Lockheed and he leaned over to me one
day in
this must have been 2007 or eight and he
said boy have I got an interesting story
for you at the time I was reporting on
terrorism he said he read was reading
what I wrote and enjoyed reading it so
what was this interesting story you know
and he said the CIA just Declassified my
life's work I invented stealth
technology or rather I was the team that
was sort of the physicists that led the
team and this goes back to an Eisenhower
was president and so as you can see this
is a remarkable lead for a reporter to
get I mean I went to the CIA and of
course you know lo and behold they had
just Declassified this aircraft program
called oxcart that took place out at
area 51 and so and then I began to work
with Lovick talking to him about his
role the science and technology role in
building this incredible aircraft and I
learned very quickly
aha there's a backstory to this
backstory and there's a lot of tangents
that are super interesting and they're
all going to fall in the access of area
51 and that's how I got that idea for
that book when did the larger public
become aware of area 51 well that's a
great question I mean and it's it's very
interesting in terms of US national
security because when you think about
what a powerful and potent site area 51
is as I report in the book the fact that
it remained almost unknown to the
general population until the early 1990s
is astonishing I mean talk about being
able to keep a secret I mean I make the
analogy in the book about the Manhattan
Project same idea right even you know
vice president Harry Truman did not know
about or Congress or Congress you know
the ones funding the program did not
know about the program so I think
secret-keeping is very interesting I
write about it in all of my books but to
your question it wasn't until a an
individual named Robert Lazar you know
squeaked this bit of news out which
landed on the edge of conspiracy
and then area 51 became known and I
think that is the origins of an
extraordinary amount of conspiracy
theory that grew out of that base and
still exists about that base and there's
still things going on there now who is
Robert Lazar well he was an interesting
let's say engineer and he was out there
at the base according to him and he saw
things that he believed were he was
working there yes and although people
will tell you he never worked there I
mean again you know the the the myths
inside the puzzles inside the conundrums
but he stood by his position that he you
know he said he saw an alien in essence
and then you get into these as I was
reporting the story all these realms of
black propaganda and you know I mean did
they dress someone up and make him look
like an alien where they tried I mean
this idea of mythology and you know
misinformation and disinformation is
part and parcel to area 51 and really to
all of the books that I have written the
subjects are conducive to that any
Jacobson you talk about you have to sign
it off
if you are working at area 51 and by the
way is a called area 51 by people who
work there as well or is that just our
yes I mean yes and no I mean originally
when I was interviewing the scientists
who worked there and the spies and the
pilots and they would call it groom lake
they would call it the ranch there were
all kinds of code names for it but and
of course what's fascinating or was to
me while I was writing the book is that
the actual word area 51 the name area 51
was classified when I was writing in the
book it since been Declassified because
President Obama referred to it publicly
that's a quick way to declassify
something but when I was looking at
those documents we were talking about
earlier the oxcart documents you would
see read be reading along and then
there'd be a small word redacted like
blacked over and if you looked at it you
know up to the light or whether you
could that's area
deewan and out of something like 7,000
pages of documents that i reviewed i
found two places where someone forgot to
black out area 51 so you would see it
there and it was an aha moment
Robert Lazar Las Vegas television what
happened well he went on TV and you know
made this claim on a local channel and I
yes in Las Vegas
yes and said that there were you know
there was that there was alien
technology and that there was an alien
out there and you know people have been
fascinated with UFOs and for millennium
I mean that is so this was like you know
setting off a match and dry grass I mean
that people went you know the story
built and it became kind of a firestorm
and I think that that has since become a
great point of contention and why area
51 is on such a lockdown issue because
people will not move off of that idea
that there are aliens out there many
people believe that and still do what
kind of cooperation did you get from the
various government agencies that you
worked with on this or tried to work
with every book is different I mean
every book is different there is kind of
a dance I think that's done with
journalists because remember the just
basic job of the journalist is to inform
the public I mean in spirit you're
really not even supposed to have an
opinion so one would think you would
want to work with transparent elements
of the government to also make things
known but I find in my experience that
current let's say like the PR office of
any of these agencies they only want to
present a certain message and that's not
that's a message not a fact let's say so
where I do most of my reporting is in
interviewing scientists who are retired
who worked on very significant programs
for these individual agencies
and are acutely aware of what they can
speak of and what they cannot because
it's still classified and because I also
write about a lot of Cold War programs
things that were incredibly interesting
and and and you know involved
extraordinary classification measures
decades ago everyone wanted to know
about them then but could not when they
become Declassified sort of the public
has moved on and I find in my experience
that by tracking down these scientists
the Superman of scientists if you will
they are willing and and and in you know
happy to share their stories about these
incredible programs because people have
lost interest and it's this idea that
you know it's important to know the past
to safeguard the future and that's the
greatest joy I think with working with
defense scientists who are dedicated
Patriots who believe in what they did
but are also especially as they get
older willing to share the pitfalls the
the failures and the press office of any
given military or intelligence agency
does not want to talk about failure
period they only want to talk about
success and I think there's a danger in
that I mean that's a theme going through
all of my books it's not to you know
ridicule a success a failure but rather
to demonstrate that failure is part of
success but we must be very careful and
you know about trying to cover up
failures how much of what goes on or did
go on at area 51 is still classified I
mean if I or don't you know is it hard
this is the analogy I mean you know it's
sometimes said I wrote the book on area
51 but if you imagine an iceberg and you
think of how much of the iceberg you see
and then how much is below the surface I
mean I probably my I'm guessing but I
probably if you planted a flag at the
top of the iceberg
that's probably what I report it in a
450
Paige book what has been what has gone
on there and what continues to gone on
boggles the mind
I mean we could talk about you know
tunnel technology for three more hours
just when you think you have what's
going on at area 51 there are a lot of
tunnel systems at that base things that
are going on there when will those be
declassified these are the great
mysteries you know I can't wait to write
area 52 have you become a Freedom of
Information request expert most
definitely I mean my kids I file so many
FOIA requests that sometimes you know
that well they often come in the mail
and they're usually those 8 by 10
envelopes and they say in the corner you
know NSA or DoD or you know CIA and
they're the thin envelopes because that
means you open up one sheet of paper and
it says request on responsive meaning
sorry we couldn't find any information
every now and then you get a bigger
envelope and that's sort of a great
moment of joy I mean that's what
happened with phenomena I I came home
one day and there was a thick manila
packet from the Central Intelligence
Agency a FOIA request had been granted
and there were you know almost a
thousand pages of documents on these ESP
and psychokinesis programs that became
the basis of phenomena that was super
interesting that's where I learned about
you know that the Apollo astronaut ed
Mitchell was doing ESP tests going to
the moon I mean the little details
inside these documents are just
priceless well let's go to phenomena
than any Jacobson you visited Edgar
Mitchell and first of all tell us who he
was but you visited to him in his last
its what yes the way I got the idea to
write phenomena sort of the spark was
researching Pentagon's brain I was
looking at the Apollo image library
because so much of DARPA has to do with
space ok it's why it's it was the
launching point of the of the
organization and I found this image and
it shows
an astronaut standing on the moon
reading a document and I thought oh my
god this this is an incredible image you
have advanced science I mean space
travel and you know proto technology
writing reading in this one image and I
had to know what that astronaut was
reading on the moon first I found out
that it was Edgar Mitchell of Hollow
14-6 man to step on the moon yes so I
went to interview him at his home in
Florida and I asked him what were you
reading on the moon and he said that he
was reading a map so I mean this is this
gets even better man on the moon reading
a map of the moon why was he reading the
map because he was lost and that to me
is just a brilliant beautiful concept
you know it's so human and it speaks to
what we were just talking about with
failures right how do you define failure
you have a program failure but then you
also have individual failure and that
often leads to people being lost or
feeling like they're lost and because I
write narrative nonfiction and because
it's character based I care about the
people I write about I want to hear
their story and how it becomes a
metaphor for the bigger story and so
with Mitchell when he told me the story
of being lost on the moon I was just you
know it's remarkable I mean the the
brief version I write it at length and
phenomena but what he said was so part
of the Apollo 14 mission and of course
keep in mind Apollo 14 comes after
Apollo 13 right the failed moon mission
there was so much pressure on them to
perform and the geologist wanted them to
go to cone crater and pull out samples
rock samples and believed that these
rock samples could perhaps reveal
Earth's origins and the moon right how I
mean what a concept you can't have meant
much more pressure on you and so he and
Alan Shepard that was their mission
so they fly 240 thousand miles to get to
the moon Mitchell was the pilot on the
antara slander he lands within 87 feet
of the target and then they get lost
locally trying to find cone crater I
mean it doesn't get more human and they
had to you know when they when they
found out they were lost and of course
this speaks to many issues of
perspective you know where do you think
you are versus where are you really in
that airless environment they they
became confused and they told NASA you
can read all these transcripts we're
lost we think we're here were there NASA
is trying to help them the heart rates
are going up they gave them NASA gave
them 30 more minutes and they couldn't
find their way to the crater and they
were told to go home you know and so
hearing from Mitchell about this
disappointment of going all the way
there and missing what turned out to be
the target by about a thousand feet you
know it's just amazing and he shared
with me how disappointed he felt on the
trip home from the moon but looking out
one of the five windows on that
spacecraft he had what he said was an
epiphany he looked out and to him he
realized that man was more than he
previously thought so he became
fascinated in that moment with the idea
of consciousness with the idea of man
what is man capable of and that's why I
think my new book phenomena is really
about the reaches of what can be known
Mitchell came home quit NASA divorced
his wife made all new friends and began
this trajectory into the world of ESP
and psychokinesis
he suffered dearly because of it some
say he got lost that's not what Mitchell
thinks why did he suffer he was
ridiculed I mean he was ridiculed you
cannot pull up any article on edy
Mitchell without kind of a snickering
journalist pointing out that he
conducted these ESP experiments on the
way to and from the moon and you know he
suffered because of it he was his all of
his
colleagues were these hard scientists he
himself was he's a PhD from MIT but he
had what is called a conversion moment
again another important theme in the
book phenomena you have scientists
physicists individuals who have these
conversion moments when dealing with
extrasensory perception psychokinesis
and they become absolutely convinced of
the reality of the phenomena and they
pursue it you know some pursue it to the
gates of hell as I write in the book and
others maintain a very scientific
attitude toward it but because the
scientific skeptic community insists
that this is pseudoscience because
rightly so
psychokinesis extrasensory perception it
does not pass scientific method muster
the five steps that every scientist
agrees must you know you must adhere to
to move from hypothesis to general
theory the most important being that
it's repeatable well ESP experiments
aren't repeatable the those you know Pro
this work say it's fickle by nature and
those against it say that's hogwash but
I love this battle there's a real battle
between you know science versus
supernatural if you will and again it
speaks to this idea of what are the far
reaches of what man can know in
phenomena annie jacobson you quote some
government documents though saying we
cannot not prove that this is not real I
mean in a sense there's some doubt there
I mean there's doubt absolutely there's
doubt everywhere but you know the CIA
concluded that the phenomena was real
but they couldn't repeat it but they
said it doesn't take away from the fact
that these real laboratory experiments
happened but now what I found most
interesting and reporting phenomena the
book was that when I began researching
and reporting I was under the impression
that the programs were buttoned up in
the mid-1990s with the kind of down
faul this one big Defense Department
program but I was astonished to learn
that they're actually back today under
the rubric of advanced cognition okay so
the Defense Department is now merging
this idea of the biological the sixth
sense the Office of Naval Research calls
it the spidey sense but instead of the
parapsychologists of the 70s and 80s
now the Defense Department is employed
neurobiologists computer technologists
computer engineers they are taking
individuals who have the spidey sense
it's just a dressed-up word for ESP and
they're looking at their brains and
they're trying to model what's going on
in their brains and then of course to
accelerate accelerate it and ultimately
weaponize it because that's the role of
the Defense Department because of your
research have you had a conversion
moment when it comes to those topics no
I mean but I will you know the Harvard
experimental psychologist Gertrude SHM
idler back in the 50s created this
system to talk about how individuals
approach this controversial subject
matter and she said on the one side
there were goats okay goats were the
scientific skeptics who said this is
nonsense this is hogwash
you know forget about all of it sheep on
the other hand were those who were open
to the idea of ESP of psychokinesis and
I would say I began as the neutral
journalist but looking at many of these
experiences reporting you know looking
at documents declassified documents and
seeing what the Defense Department
thinks what the CIA thinks talking to
the scientists talking to the physicists
talking to the psychics I kind of
shifted a little bit toward sheep like I
am open to the idea that it is unknown
that the you know the conclusions are
not yet in I really think that is the
idea of
the far reaches of what can be known for
me it's wiser to lean sheep to not
discount not throw out the baby with the
bathwater if you will are there aliens
at area 51 let's go to it I mean that's
right that is that's what everyone I
mean that's the first question you're
always asked isn't it certainly we're
talking about area 51 I mean so I
interviewed you know 75 people for area
51 all of whom had direct access to that
base all of whom went on record one
source remained anonymous with me
because he gave me what was then where
what still is according to him
classified information
he was an Atomic Energy Commission
scientist and he told me this shocking
story in the end of the area 51 book you
know it takes up 12 pages in the end of
the book and it's what you know Garner's
the most curiosity and what he told me
was that there was a program out there
that he worked on which was a black
propaganda program to create creatures
that looked like aliens and it involved
human experimentation and he was very
parsimonious with the details
but he was very succinct with going on
the record about this and you know I
interviewed him for over a hundred hours
and by the way stayed in contact with
him after the book published and
continued to have discussions with him
and he sticks by that idea so the read
on area 51 as I tell the story as he
told it to me is they were not errant
they were not aliens this doesn't mean
that there's not extraordinary material
that continues to you know swirl around
the cauldron about why his information
is incorrect it's a big puzzle but I I
really appreciated his candor with me
and I stand by
everything that he spoke of and that I
reported in the book and he stood by it
all the way to his death and welcome to
book TV on c-span - this is our in-depth
program we have one author on talk about
his or her body of work and this month
its author Annie Jacobson her books
area51 an uncensored history of
America's top secret military base came
out in 2011 Operation Paperclip the
secret intelligence program that brought
Nazi scientists to America came out in
2014 the Pentagon's brain an uncensored
history of DARPA America's top-secret
military research agency came out in
2015 and her most recent book is
fenomena the secret history of the US
government's investigation into
extrasensory perception and
psychokinesis just out this year she'll
be our guests for the next two and a
half hours and if you have questions or
comments you'd like to make with Annie
Jacobsen here's the way you can contact
us you can dial in on the telephone 2:02
is the area code seven four eight eighty
two hundred for those of you in the East
and Central time zones seven four eight
eight two zero one if you live in the
mountain and Pacific time zones now if
you can't get through on the phone lines
still want to make a comment
try social media at book TV is our
Twitter handle you can also make a
comment on our Facebook page
facebook.com slash book TV you'll see
her picture there you can make a comment
right underneath there and you could
also send us an email at book TV at
c-span dot o-r-g and we'll begin taking
your calls in just a few minutes
annie jacobson were you able to get any
dollar figures on how much is spent at
area 51 how much is spent on researching
psychokinesis wooded Operation Paperclip
cost and DARPA what's their budget all
of the program's I write about almost
all of them are what are called special
access programs SAP programs they exist
in these very secret classification
protocols that are far above normal
classified
so it is almost impossible to accurately
say what the budgets are the the one of
the budgets I can give you is that the
DARPA budget that's public so DARPA
spends three billion dollars a year and
that is the case that's basically been
the same figure if you adjust it for
inflation going back to DARPA origin in
1958
it's an extraordinary amount of money
for a hundred and twenty program
managers but that's only the public
figure so all of the programs are
dealing with black budgets which means
that the money is essentially unknowable
on that subject I'll give you one
fascinating detail that I find that
maybe stands is the best analogy for all
of this so in area 51 the one of the
kind of creators of area 51 if you will
was Richard Bissell he was with it he
was deputy director of the CIA and the
way in which he became involved in area
51 if you back up a couple years he got
a call from Allen Dulles at CIA saying
hey listen Bissell at the time Bissell
was in charge of the Marshall fund okay
that was the plan to rebuild Europe
after World War two an extraordinary
amount of money
Bissell was in charge of it and Dulles
said and I'm paraphrasing but this is
the essence can you skim some of that
money off of the Marshall fund and give
it to us for a secret program Bissell
said you should again paraphrasing you
sure I should do this yes Bissell did it
and years later he found out when he was
made sort of the director of the area 51
project remember that money you gave us
here's what it went to this is how area
51 was set up so these things are and
interestingly Bissell talks about that
in his memoir so you can find
information I as a reporter find
information in a whole array of places
from memoirs - you know papers that are
stored at different archives individuals
journals sometimes the family gives me
access to them for requests interviews
this is the joy of being a journalist
you have many different sources you're
pulling from to try and pee
together the story for the reader as
best you can somebody who plays a part
in several of your books Edward Teller I
mean almost all of them you know I begin
the pentagon's brain with this talk
about a colossal failure I mean and
again others will say this was a
colossal win so the castle Bravo bomb I
mean this was a thermonuclear weapon
Edward Teller the father of the hydrogen
bomb and it's you know the average
person think so atomic weaponry
thermonuclear bombs same same cookie
sheet well perhaps except for in orders
of magnitude
I mean thermonuclear weapons can take
one thermonuclear weapon could take out
the eastern seaboard
there was one thermonuclear weapon
exploded in Castle Bravo the castle
Bravo bomb out in the Marshall Islands I
begin the Pentagon's brain with it you
know from the perspective of witnesses
who were there who told me their story
when I say colossal failure it was
supposed to be six and a half megatons
but it went out of control
I mean tellers calculation and all the
scientists working with him they
couldn't you know predict the future
they couldn't predict their own science
experiment and instead it was a runaway
thermonuclear bomb 15 megatons I mean
just an astonishing amount of power
energy and apocalyptic by its very
nature well he he shows up at area 51
and he shows up again in Pentagon's
brain and Operation Paperclip the whole
the whole gamut I mean he said he's a
super interesting character I mean many
people again would say he had hubris and
that he was trying to outdo his arch
rival Oppenheimer riot other people will
say he saved us from you know Soviet
invasion because you know the he pushed
the idea of the development of the
thermonuclear bomb which some of his
colleagues by the way called the evil
thing okay they did not think these are
Manhattan
they did not think it should be
developed because it could end the world
Taylor pushed for it and ultimately won
and he was also involved with SDI yes I
mean he gets pulled into the program
during the Reagan administration I mean
he and again I've interviewed people who
swear by his benefit beneficence and
when I say that I mean because the
castle Bravo bomb which was a secret
program no one even knew it went on at
the time you know we found out later
that the Russians were only you know
literally months behind us in the
development of their thermonuclear
weapon and in this idea of the Battle of
the superpowers a theme through all of
the books you know the US government
must stay ahead and what's interesting
is it does stay ahead so to give credit
where credit is due and when I was
interviewing DARPA scientists who said
when we got into the realm of you know
cloning let's say I mean you've got
thermonuclear weapons as part of the
origin story and today you have you know
autonomous weapons artificial
intelligence biotechnology bio hybrids
human cyborgs this is all DARPA
scientists science and the DARPA
scientists would say to me when I would
ask questions like is this wise they
would say well what if you were to wake
up and tomorrow morning and find out
that the Chinese or the Russians or even
a dark horse like Saudi Arabia presented
the world with the first cloned human
clone you know would Americans say my
god we've been beaten by an enemy nation
that's why DARPA exists that's why these
weapons program exists why area 51
exists it's why paperclip existed we
must stay ahead of the rest of the world
so that we are not beaten by
technological surprise and so far we
have twenty eight billion dollars is the
figure you cite for the development of
the nuclear bomb in your book
two hundred thousand employees kept
secret from Congress Oak Ridge Tennessee
took more power than New York City more
electrical power I mean I use that as an
example whenever anyone says
oh come on you can't really believe the
government can keep secrets they're not
capable of doing that you know it's a
conspiracy to think otherwise well I
sight exactly that I mean of course the
government can and does keep secrets and
then the other side of the argument is
it needs to somebody lost to history but
plays a role in the early development of
some of this is Vannevar Bush who was he
well he was the scientific director of
the Manhattan Project and also of sort
of so we're going back in time now to
the years right before America entered
World War two and there was an
extraordinary sense of isolationism in
America you know we didn't want to enter
the war and didn't feel that we that we
needed to or should but at the same time
the president needed to make sure that
we were keeping up with the science and
technological advances that we knew the
Nazis were making thanks to people like
Einstein who had already come here you
know so you have secret science that's
really where I think secret science
began with Vannevar Bush and with these
pre-war technologies America was hedging
her bets rightly so
because you know you can't start your
atomic weapons program when the Nazis
are working on their triggering system
Annie Jacobson is our guest let's hear
from CJ in Marietta Georgia hi CJ good
afternoon
actually I have recently been
interfacing with a gentleman actually
that worked for Oprah at national
laboratory for over 40 years he
contacted me because he also knew I
worked for one of the largest defense
contractors what's interesting is the
Manhattan Project that you actually are
speaking of but he went in great length
about sharing with me that he just felt
my personality without Goering and
therefore he wanted to find some of the
the children original burner some of the
scientists excellent african-american
scientist be specific that actually
worked on the Manhattan Project and I
over the course of the Christmas holiday
for about three weeks
I contacted various agencies paternity
organizations and was able to find five
children of some of the individuals that
worked on the Manhattan Project and it
was very interesting one of the guys who
is a doctor in Washington DC now said
that his father kept journals and we're
going to be meeting with him here in the
Atlanta metro area in the next few weeks
about most various things but what was
very interesting the gentleman said is
his father never talked about his work
and that you know he would be gone for
months years at a time
and as you indicated the secrecy there
were over 200,000 employees that
actually worked on the Manhattan Project
and within Oak Ridge National you know
Oak Ridge Tennessee were actually I was
reared and I never even knew about it
until I met this gentleman mr. of
interactor who had worked for them for
many years and so the secrecy that
actually exists both with the area 51
project with National Laboratory and
others across the United States is so
mind-boggling to me it just you know
we're here you know years later finding
out about all these secret projects and
things that happen but it's a lot of
that and we will never know about it
unless so we're journalists like
yourself and that actually bring these
things up that what's going on and
oftentimes we're not aware why the
United States are going into debt
because of these types of projects Thank
You CJ any comment for her
I mean it's you know you've touched upon
a very important theme for this not only
the individuals who work on their
programs but their families and it's why
I love tracking down and interviewing
the children if the if the the parents
have
past the scientists because you can kind
of get a sense of that secrecy the
children knew nothing in many cases and
also the wives knew nothing but a lot of
times they have and will share you know
fathers papers that are stored in the
Attic and so that becomes this idea of
legacy I think is very interesting and I
particularly found that when I worked on
paperclip and I went to Germany and
interviewed the children of some of
these major Nazis who worked for Hitler
and then later worked for the Department
of Defense
what was your reception like in Germany
you know what it was either black or
white I mean and that really was
astonishing it was either no I don't
want to talk to you father didn't do
anything wrong never mind he was a
convicted war criminal I'm speaking
specifically about a convicted war
criminals Oh Ambrose who was Hitler's
chemical weapons developer and he was
convicted of as I write in paperclip he
was convicted of mass murder slavery
genocide sent to Landsberg prison after
the Nuremberg trials and then was
released by our US High Commissioner
John McCloy and what went back into the
world and then consulted for the Atomic
Energy Commission I mean when I tried to
track when I did track down his son and
tried to interview him he said my father
did nothing wrong he was acquitted on
the other hand I interviewed other
children of major Nazis who had a very
different take and were very thoughtful
and remorseful and courageous in sharing
with me the profound difficulty of you
know that legacy that they must live
with I mean on the one hand the son
cannot be judged by the father but
psychologically it's an extraordinary
burden to bear so interviewing people
who are that forthcoming with me about
you know the complications of that
legacy I mean I feel like that
undergirds the
with significance that's deeply
emotional 1600 Nazi scientists or so
came over via Operation Paperclip how
deep did their tentacles go here in this
country I mean they were in every
weapons program that we were financing
there was a top Nazi I mean that's a
gross generalization but I think it is
also very accurate certainly from my
reporting I mean in my book I focus on
21 of the Nazis who I found to be
extreme cases extreme meaning they
during the war they worked directly with
Hitler Himmler you know Speer and so
when you when you think about that but
then they were working for us with us
that's real drama in there so I looked
at 21 but there are 1,600 and just from
looking at those big files and sort of
mapping out where everyone went
yes they were in every one of our
weapons program and I think I read that
one of those Nazi scientists was the
first director of the Kennedy Space
Center Kurt Davis you know they still
give out the Kurt Debus award does a
kind of the most innovative thinker in
this world and I was shocked to find out
this because of the the documents that I
was able to get from a Freedom of
Information Act indicate that dev Debus
was a hardcore Nazi I mean he even wore
the SS uniform to work in Nazi Germany
he turned in a colleague ratted out a
colleague for saying mean things about
his Hitler literally and this guy got
picked up by the Gestapo and you know
we're giving him an award I mean this
kind of thing is astonishing I called up
the head of the of the of the
organization that gives that award and
you know he's very defensive and he said
Davos was a great innovator and he you
know did all these things for the Apollo
program and I said but what do you say
to the person who says to you he was a
Nazi and his response was very
interesting he said no one's ever
asked me that question before so we have
journalism to present the facts and let
people decide what they think about
those facts was it known contemporarily
that he was a former Nazi and now he's
running the Kennedy Space Center a lot
of these guys was that known very
important question absolutely not and
from the declassified documents I
learned that not only did NASA know
about their past but they were complicit
in making sure that this did not get out
this was a this was a kind of a quote
from one of the Von Braun documents
because von Braun because he was so
high-profile Wernher von Braun yes he
was always being kind of pulled into it
by journalists who would ask him
questions about his Nazi past he was
told by NASA to say if you're asked your
answer should be
I've been thoroughly investigated by the
US military and he had been thoroughly
investigated they just didn't reveal
what the investigation had found so you
were able to make some inroads in
Germany have you been to DARPA
headquarters here in the Washington area
have you actually set foot in area 51 I
have not been to DARPA headquarters
they're very secretive about letting
anybody in there I mean they like to
present the idea that they are a
beneficent organization and you know
they do do some great things we have the
Internet the results of a lot of their
work have profoundly impacted society
and made it easier for a lot of people
but let's face it
DARPA z' job as was indicated in its
early mandate you know in 1958 is to
create vast weapon systems of the future
so DARPA is very you know secretive
about letting anyone in and and seeing
what's really going on
area 51 no journalist has ever been
there including me I was taken by a
group of former Manhattan Project
scientists when they were still alive to
the Neva what was then called the Nevada
site which is you know all the other
areas areas 1 to 10 15 20 that align
with area if you want area 51's are over
the hill in your own ticaboo Pete yes
yes and well no I was actually in the
test site which is where all the bomb
craters are and you're kind of driving
through the desert and you see where you
know a an old safe was blown up like a
big giant Bank safe to try it these were
parts of the test to see what would
survive a small nuclear blast train
tracks you know the rubble that's out
there in the desert is remarkable the
area is all you know concealed so I went
there and I kind of saw area 51 five
miles away but that's the close as I got
to Travis is calling in from Eureka
California hi Travis you're on with
author Annie Jacobson hello good
afternoon I'm interested in remote
viewing and what if any evidence that
you researched did you find a be the
most convincing in favor of it being you
no effect
so thanks for the question remote
viewing for those who might not know is
another word for extrasensory perception
and it was a term created by the CIA in
the 1970s to D stigmatize the concept of
ESP the concept of psychics of psychic
functioning it became part and parcel to
all of the programs that went on for the
next 25 years across the CIA across the
Department of Defense over at DIA which
is the Defense Intelligence Agency and
as I write in the book phenomena there's
there are extraordinary success stories
of remote viewing locating hostages
locating downed aircraft
there are also colossal failures and
again I tell both of those stories in
the book and I let you decide but when
you look at the facts of what some of
these psychics were able to accomplish
were able to see
know the unknowable with a CIA or
Defense Department handler sitting with
them inside of what was usually a
Faraday cage an electronically shielded
room so there's no way they could be
getting information any other way other
than this mysterious Sixth Sense which
no one has been able to explain so I
would say the remote viewing success
stories exist and I write about them in
the book
the Pentagon's brain was a finalist for
the Pulitzer and this email comes in
from Chris in Houston Texas and he or
she asks how does DARPA research make
its way from being purely military to
something a company can sell to the
public at large great about GPS okay
I mean satellite technology
interestingly finds some of its origins
at area 51 Richard Bissell who we talked
about earlier the the sort of mayor of
area 51 along with doctor bud Whelan who
I interviewed for the book they were
working early satellite technologies as
they were running these airplane
technology programs they were also
experimenting with satellites hoped it
would work I mean think about that as a
concept in terms of innovation our whole
military runs you know with the
satellite system being at the center but
in the 50s and 60s these ideas were just
coming online and there was a mandate
over at the Defense Department to you
know create what we now know as GPS
through satellite technology and it took
decades to really come to fruition but
when DARPA finally was able to make
these systems work and this is kind of
at the end of the Vietnam War this was
an important was the military targeting
technology GPS that you have in your
smartphone okay and it was kept secret
it had an offset by a couple hundred
feet so if anyone hat into our system
they wouldn't be able to target the
another brahms would be off in essence
and it was kept secret all the way
through the 90s and during the Clinton
administration
word came down that a European civilian
organization was going to develop GPS
for the consumer and that is why the
Clinton administration Declassified GPS
technology because we wanted America to
be able to be the innovators and the
primary drivers of that in the
commercial world and that's exactly what
you see l st. Petersburg Florida
good afternoon now your own book TV good
afternoon folks
miss Dickinson in your book phenomenon
do you mention a person named Ingo Swann
I sure do they called Ingo Swann the
original super psychic and he played a
very significant role in the early years
of the CIA program and also in the years
of the Defense Department program so
there's quite a bit you can read about
in phenomena about Swann he was a very
charismatic person and a fascinating
character al why do you ask about him
with him in California in 69 when I was
a Scientologist and he well doesn't
that's one of my questions was anybody
in Scientology taken seriously in the
phenomenon program and Ingo Swann had
contempt for the people who reached ot 3
and other levels he says hell I can do
what cost you thousands of thousands of
dollars you know with my hands tied
behind my back the other thing there's
two other things I'd like to mention to
you that may be interested in and maybe
some other time not on this program I
could contact you if you're interested
but there is a study and University of
Virginia done about 30 years ago that
has real that scientifically proves
things that that tie in with what you're
doing it would be an extended
conversation I don't know if you want to
have it now well probably we don't have
time now al but we appreciate your
calling in I think you do have a website
we'll put that up on the on the screen
if you wish
contact Annie Jacobson go ahead the
scientology question is very interesting
of course
the intelligence community and the
Defense Department were extremely anti
Scientologists but you're absolutely
correct that Ingo Swann and others in
the program had been involved in
Scientology and it becomes a great point
of contention and it also isn't there
are some mysteries that remain and I
think the biggest mysteries that remain
surround a psychic that worked at the
same time as Ingo Swann for the CIA and
his name was Pat price and Pat price
sort of all PE outperformed Ingo Swann
in the psychic realm if you will because
whereas Swann was it was incredibly
gifted at describing you know using his
ESP talents if you will to describe
situations narrative Lee colorfully Pat
price could pull actual names numbers
figures off of documents in classified
facilities thousands of miles away and
he was so good at this that a number of
security investigations high-level
investigations came down on him because
people could not possibly fathom how he
could know what he did he died in 1975
under very mysterious circumstances many
conspiracies have arisen about what he
died one of them is that the Church of
Scientology killed him
Annie Jacobson do conspiracy theorists
come to your book events oh yes I mean I
did this great event with the one of the
scientific skeptics named professor
Michael Shermer at Caltech and this was
for the area 51 book and he filled this
auditorium I mean it must have sat 400
people and because it's in Pasadena
right near JPL the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory it was sort of like half of
the people in the room were these big
brains from JPL and the other half were
conspiracy theorists and you know we had
this lively
raucous debate not just me asking
questions but then the question started
going back and forth and sometimes they
weren't questions sometimes they were
like shouting at one another but I think
these are all important readers to have
because I find that conspiracy theories
often have roots in truth and I write
about this in every one of my books
where you have an alleged conspiracy
theory which is actually you know part
of a black propaganda campaign or a
disinformation campaign and again I'm
able to unearth these documents have
them Declassified and demonstrate that
things are not always exactly as they
seem what any of your four books exist
were it not for the Cold War in Russia
no no no they're all a product of that
race the arms race between the United
States and the Soviet Union and often
China comes in pardon me George email I
believe Bob Lazar
said that element 1 1 5 was the power
source for the alien technology that he
was trying to reverse-engineer since
then element 1 1 5 has been synthesized
and is apparently not possibly a
credible power source any comment little
to inside baseball for me I interviewed
Lazar for the book area 51 I write about
my interview with him but what I think
the caller or the the individual is
speaking to the fact that these ideas
these mysteries some would call them
conspiracies these are not going away
people continue to be interested because
they feel that their questions have not
been answered and that of course speaks
to this idea that we've been talking
about about you know transparency
government transparency what can be
known what should be known why do we
have to wait decades to have these
documents Declassified you also write
about Janet Airlines what is that
Janet Airlines is the the private
Airlines that flies from Las Vegas to
area 51 it has its own conspiracies
within conspiracies I mean I had someone
contact me just recently and say you
know give me the Janet airline schedules
and they stopped flying during the day
apparently and they only fly at night I
mean again these these mysteries and
conspiracies fold within one another and
they don't want to end why are they
called Janet Airlines and you describe
the interior and landing what it's like
there have you been on Janet Airlines
you have to be invited like you know
many places certainly area 51 you have
to be invited out there but but what is
interesting is in all of my books it
researching you know the Superman of or
interviewing the Superman of science lo
and behold almost embrace is oh by the
way I read your area 51 book and I was
out there and then they tell me the
little program that they were on Dale
Graff one of the leading scientists in
my new book phenomena he was out at area
51 I said Dale that's incredible tell me
you know what were you doing out there I
can't tell you let's hear from Joel in
Eagle Idaho hi Joel hi Peter hey great
program my father was a b-29 pilot over
in Tinian where the Enola Gay took off
he never talked much about it but he
ended up at Bell Aircraft in Niagara
Falls New York now there was a program
there ICBM program and I can remember a
picture of him and Wernher von Braun
eventually Bela got into the x1x2
programs but you never heard I never
heard much about whatever happened to
von Braun after he was at Bell Bell was
the Bell Helicopter plant of course but
what can you tell me about Wernher von
Braun and where he ended up and what he
ended up doing thank you sir it's a
great question and there's another
former Nazi general operation paperclip
scientists who wound up at Bell and that
was walter dornberger and i write about
him in Operation Paperclip as well so
von
Brown had an interesting trajectory I
mean he worked all the way through the
Apollo program and then retired and went
into private enterprise and then he was
stricken with cancer and died but you
know Ron Brown comes up in every one of
my books there's a fascinating story
where he loops in with the in the in the
book that I've just written phenomena
with Uri Geller of all people who you
know was a CIA asset and who got that
had the Defense Department very
concerned with psychokinesis so spoon
bending what Geller does and many people
tell you that he's a magician
the DoD did not think so the CIA did not
think so
and they were concerned that what Geller
could do with psychokinesis was think of
the delicate electronic system in an
ICBM they were concerned if Geller could
bend a spoon with the tip of his finger
that hit using his mind he could do the
same he could disrupt the electronic
system and so when he came to the United
States he met with Wernher von Braun and
there's a photograph I have of the two
of them in phenomena but von Braun was
fascinated with Geller Geller got von
Browns watch to stop and he made this
statement like I have no scientific
explanation for how he did this and
Geller got an old desk calculator that
von Braun had that was that it stopped
working Geller got it to start working
just by touching it and you know this
mystified von Braun and because he was
such a powerful figure in the science
community it raised a lot of eyebrows
that von Braun was you know taken with
Geller we had on this program a year or
two back
Jonathan Ronson none Ronson who uh the
men who stare at goats is that tie into
some of the things that you write about
in phenomenon it does I mean that's the
remote viewing program and one of the
things that I demonstrate you know over
time happened with the fenomena program
was that the CIA
was under the impression that this
talent okay which was still in the
hypothesis stage this you know let's
call it enhanced intuition or enhanced
perception the CIA doctors believed that
it's biological that it's
individualistic that use the Mozart
analogy think of how I know I cannot
sing in the shower and then you listen
to Mozart's amazing music and you know
wow that's different that's biology okay
that's the metaphor that the CIA used
because they believed that individual
people Ingo Swann Pat price early Geller
had some kind of extraordinary gift that
the rest of us didn't the Defense
Department took a different approach
they believed that soldiers could be
trained to become psychic and grave
problems arose because the CIA advised
against this the Defense Department
pursued it and it led to a lot of
program a lot of problems within these
programs because in many cases you had
soldiers you know trying to be psychic
and having very little success and at
the same time you had individual people
who were actually psychic if you will
working on these programs and having
success and it created a catch-22
because the Defense Department didn't
want to believe that people were psychic
because it flew in the face of science a
lot of corporations are involved in a
lot of your books and a lot of this
weren't the RAND Corporation Raytheon
Vannevar Bush I believe was a founder of
that Raytheon Corporation a lot of money
to be made on these projects you know
this is a very important subject defense
contracting it speaks to what
Eisenhower's said on his farewell speech
about the military-industrial complex
and the warning area that I saw was when
I was reporting the Pentagon's brain and
I learned that
the Jason scientists okay so now if you
want to talk conspiracy I mean the Jason
scientists come up in everybody's in all
the world of conspiracy who are the
Jason's so they are allegedly this you
know before I interviewed a lot of the
Jason's one idea is that they're kind of
the Illuminati of the defense science
world so I interviewed Marvin Goldberger
who everyone calls Murph
right before he died who was the founder
of the Jason's and worked on many of
these DARPA projects for decades and the
Jason scientists what I found to be most
interesting was they were full-time
professors you know at the great
universities across America and
part-time defense scientists so they
would get together in the summers and
solve for DARPA whatever conundrums
DARPA was facing they were called the
Superman of science and what I learned
in the recent era in the modern era is
there has been a shift and the Defense
Department DARPA in particular has kind
of moved the Jason scientists to the
side they still consult but they're not
as important I was told and what is
important now in terms of setting you
know setting policy and making decisions
about what science projects will be
pursued in the future isn't an
organization inside the Pentagon called
the defense Science Board the dsb and as
I write very specifically in the
Pentagon's brain if you look at the
individuals who are on the defense
Science Board they are almost all
full-time defense contractors they are
not part-time defense scientists and so
what you have is what Eisenhower warned
us against which is the very people who
are deciding which weapon systems which
vast weapon systems of the future the
Pentagon will pursue are the same
individuals who stand to make an
extraordinary amount of money on those
weapon systems who runs DARPA
today do you know DARPA is director less
at the moment but DARPA is really
managed by these hundred and twenty
program managers as I said earlier three
billion dollars in the hands of a
hundred and twenty program managers they
have extraordinary power to stop and
start programs they look outside of the
military establishment as well and work
with the universities and research labs
so profoundly innovative I mean this is
the true definition of blue sky research
DARPA leads the question is you know do
we like where they're leading us and the
answer is you don't have a need to know
about that because most of the really
intense programs that DARPA is working
on artificial intelligence autonomous
weapons these are classified programs
Jake in West Hollywood California thanks
for holding you're on with author Andy
Jacobson thanks for taking my call
I was just wondering you're talking
about money now is there any mechanism
by which the United States gets money
from the companies that use DARPA s--
innovations because I know if you read
the biography of Steve Jobs or Bill
Gates or any of these people they always
have a stop off at DARPA I know the
screen for smartphones things out there
so are we making deals where we get paid
for that stuff thank you
well the way the money flows from DARPA
is it flows out of DARPA into the hands
of the laboratories that are developing
the weapons programs so yes you know if
if Apple has a product that DARPA wants
to develop they would be paid does that
answer the question he is he is gone so
let's hope that that does answer the
question I think he's looking for is
there a return on this investment in a
sense well I would say the return on the
investment happens in the civilian
sector I mean if you make a product if
you if
you let me maybe give a better example
so I interviewed for the Pentagon's
brain some scientists who are working
down at UC Irvine on limb regeneration
okay this is the idea think of the
salamander loses its tail it grows back
okay these scientists believe that
humans will one day be capable of
regenerating their own limbs straw
dinerral II interesting to DARPA in
terms of you know you know wounded
warriors but this kind of research is 20
30 years out but the scientists at
Irvine told me is who's gonna fund that
no one except for DARPA so DARPA is
willing to invest in very early
laboratory research that leads to
extraordinary new things the scientists
that I'm that I spoke to and that I
write about in the book working on this
program we're very grateful for this
funding from DARPA because it allows
them to continue their research and to
seek grants elsewhere so there is a
give-and-take in this world that has to
do with money coming in and new programs
going out one of the characters in the
Pentagon's brain
Michael gold/black who is he well
Goldblatt was the individual who really
took biological science to a new level
okay so back up for a minute researching
the Pentagon's brain I was fascinated by
the idea that the hard science of those
days missile technology weapon you know
did not involve biological scientists so
that happened ironically when the wall
came down and you had Soviet biological
weapons engineers defecting to the
United States and bringing with them the
big reveal that the Soviets were
breaking the biological weapons treaty
and developing these horrific weapons
you know mixing things like Ebola and in
flu
Enza okay to create apocalyptic results
so when these scientists arrived and
began working for DARPA it led to this
idea of we need to look inside the body
we need to look at human biology and
that's where Goldblatt enters the scene
because about that same time computer
we're now kind of in the in the in the
90s okay the early 90s and computers are
now computer technology is getting small
so we're moving moving toward
nanotechnology and the Defense
Department now becomes very interested
in the idea of human physiology what
individual soldiers are capable of how
you can enhance that and how you can
ultimately create a super soldier and
you know Goldblatt led the way all the
way through the late 90s and early 2000s
and there was a lot of kickback from
this from the public one of the programs
I think that that sums this up with
something called the robo rat okay so
the idea was ultimately to be able to
put computer technology inside humans
and an early prototype was the rat so
they wired up this rat and they were
able to quit the chip in his brain DARPA
scientists were able to steer the rat
through a maze
well people cried foul and said you know
this is right at the edge of ethics and
you cannot be doing this kind of thing
it's only going to lead in a bad
direction and so the programs were
somewhat curtailed well then 9/11
happened and there was an extraordinary
amount of funding and now these DARPA
programs today that I write about at
length in the Pentagon's brain involve
you know pushing the biology of humans
in another direction and ultimately
merging man and machine to create what
used to be relegated to science fiction
and that is the human cyborg Michael
Goldblatt began his career at McDonald's
he did he did I mean and he was
recruited by DARPA it's a it's a pretty
interesting story about how you know he
he developed a system that dealt with
sterilization
technology for McDonald's on the wake of
a one of those bacterial scandals that
you know really put the fast-food
restaurants in in a lot of trouble and
so the sterilization technology he
thought there has to be a military
application for this and DARPA agreed
with him and he ended up becoming a very
powerful player there
Kathleen's calling from Los Angeles hi
Kathleen hi hello I just wanted to speak
about ions I'm the co-chair of the
co-chair of the LA ions group which is
the organization that Edgar Mitchell
started to marry science and
spirituality physics and metaphysics but
I just had to comment on growing limbs
because as an acupuncturist I have a I
have a YouTube video of me fixing a
paralyzed dog in six treatments with my
electromagnetic field stimulator but I
wanted to comment on Edgar Mitchell in
his last two years we Skyped him in to
the ions convention in Chicago as well
as the contact in the desert conference
here in Joshua Tree where he spoke about
his career and being on the other side
of the Moon saying how craters had no
lava because they're all went towards
our side but I was able to talk to him
on the phone and asked him about the
evidence that Armstrong and his
colleagues had run into aliens when they
were going coming back from the moon and
when they were on the moon and they
reported this on their private line to
their doctor not to the public line that
we would hear about and then this was
picked up by shortwave radio people that
they were reporting that they were you
know there were there were people around
them they were you know aliens there
with him on the moon and I asked him if
he'd ever had that experience or if he
had heard that from Armstrong and he
declined at that time I don't know
whether he has things they didn't want
to share but I just thought that it's
such a wonderful organization with that
he started and we would love to have you
come and speak at one of our monthly
meetings because right now our main
project is is Fukushima the extinction
level event and why is being ignored and
we have a former NASA scientist who has
the remedy for it but it needs billions
of dollars after six years and so you
know why are these things ignored and I
don't know it's just Mary Kathleen what
is the eye on Society the Institute of
noetic Sciences which was started by
Edgar Mitchell after that epiphany and
they do a lot of research as I'm sure
Annie can elaborate on you know up they
have a campus up in Marin and they do a
lot of psychokinetic research it's very
science-based and it's showing the you
know the underlying you know in other
words when I lecture I call my lecture
the electrum the human electromagnetic
laser body and that's what we really
have you know we have so many more
possibilities and potential in our
bodies and of course this organization
is just looking into that thank you man
are you familiar with this organization
so Edgar Mitchell came back from the
moon after that epiphany quit NASA
divorced his wife made all new friends
and started this organization it had a
couple different names in the early
years but it became a front for the CIA
and I found that fascinating
he became very involved in all of this
and he is actually the individual who
brought Geller
to the United States and he was the
front for the CIA in doing that because
Geller was such a hugely popular figure
they needed to mask the idea that he was
actually being tested by the CIA at the
Stanford Research Institute are you
familiar with Kathleen and her work no
no no William is in is LAN DIA New York
hi William yeah I had one question a
couple of questions if you know anything
about the Philadelphia Experiment and
the time travels at Montauk Long Island
and the secret onyx spaceships with the
Nazis
and the Hitler time bell and the alien
bases on the far side of the moon and
that was it thank you sir
yeah Annie Jacobson any response for him
so we've talked a lot about conspiracies
and how they kind of weave their way
through this this because I write of all
right about these subjects from a CIA or
DoD filter for me it's interesting to
look at how these organizations deal
with these subject matters and usually
it creates great problems so because you
are for example in the book phenomena if
you're prone to ESP if you're prone to
psychokinesis for a lot of these
individuals that leads to other ideas
that are along the lines of what the the
readers the caller was talking about and
as I report in the book it became a real
problem at DoD because they didn't know
how to set ground rules like you can
think and talk about aliens but it has
to occur at home outside of the military
environment and instead you had a couple
of these individuals these soldiers who
were using government time government
money to conduct their own experiments
using remote viewing using ESP to try to
you know do all these sort of ideas that
the callers talking about and locate
aliens around the world and you know the
declassified documents on this are
fascinating because DoD did not know how
to put a lid on this because they were
concerned I don't know if it was
upsetting people or they just didn't and
so it created a colossal problem and
ultimately it kind of led to the
downfall of the program Harry
Stevensville Montana email two questions
are you aware of magicians both retired
and working that actively debunk
paranormal phenomena for the benefit of
the public at large yes and I write I
write about them in the book because in
phenomena in phenomena because it's
important to address both sides of
the aisle on this issue you know there's
no doubt that magicians can bend spoons
using pre digit station that's what they
call it I mean you can watch a million
YouTube video is demonstrating exactly
that the question is whether or not hury
Geller or someone like him can bend a
spoon not using a magic trick and I
write at length about that debate that
battle that is science versus
supernatural at its heart second
question from Harry in Stevensville
Montana
are you aware of the James Randi
Educational Foundation offer to pay 1
million dollars to anyone who can
exhibit any paranormal phenomena under
controlled conditions if so have you
talked with mr. Randy yes I interviewed
Randy for the book you know I am
fascinated but because I write about war
and weapons I'm fascinated by battles
and feuds both personal political global
and Randy and Uri Geller had this
decades-long battle over this subject
and you know they both all these decades
later stand by their ideas one says this
is hogwash the other says this is a
biological talent so the reader might be
interested to see that debate play out
as it does in phenomena hopefully from a
neutral point of view you know showing
different declassified documents on the
subject showing what the DoD thought of
Randy what they thought of Geller what
they were saying how they all played a
role because their their feud elevated
all of this to a to a public dialogue so
that is interesting also because here
they are making this an issue and the
Defense Department and the CIA are
trying to keep it all secret let's hear
from Bob and Overland Park Kansas Bob
you're on with author Andy Jacobson on
book TV hi Peter great to talk to you
again and I really am interested in the
Annie's book I got up to chapter 11
I'm really interested in a couple of
threads that you have in there one is
the early research that was done in
psychedelics and their relation to
psychic ability the other thing is the
degree to which there was something of
an arms race between the Russians and
the Americans in terms of trying to
figure out how you could explore the
military uses of remote viewing psychic
research etc the other thing is I used
to live in California and met Russell
Targ and and it was fascinated with his
work and remote viewing did you have an
opportunity to interview him for your
book and then I have another thing I'll
just leave you with and and since you
have done a lot of investigative
reporting with DARPA initiative you
mentioned earlier that Edward Teller has
his feet and so many different strands
well there's a new thing that has been
emerging in terms of geoengineering and
it was Edward Teller that came up with a
first concept for geoengineering in
terms of how could we possibly mitigate
the effects of EMP with may be doing
aerosolization of metallic substances
and aerosols in the atmosphere which are
now being touted as possible solutions
to mitigating climate change and the
effects of global what's here from Annie
Jacobson thank you Bob so your first
question is super interesting to me
because it speaks to the origins of the
psychic program and again it pulls from
that original cache of NOC Nazi
documents that were discovered by
operational sauce after the after the
war so one of the early ideas that the
CIA was following with psychokinesis
with ESP had to do with
psychopharmacology which is a fancy name
for drugs this pulled from an old Aztec
legend of hallucinogenic mushrooms the
idea that the shaman would take
hallucinogenic mushrooms and their
divinatory powers would be enhanced so
they'd be able to tell you what was
happening what was going to happen in
the few
or tell you who stole your donkey okay
so it had like prophecy and intelligence
collection this got the CIA's attention
and they hired a man a medical doctor
who is at the army chemical Center named
Andreya park and you know he has a foot
in many conspiracy theories as well
because he was a someone who worked on
the MKULTRA programs so again these
themes weave through all of my books
with elements of truth
yes there really was a program that the
CIA ran MKULTRA sub-project 58 that
sought to pursue hallucinogenic
mushrooms for intelligence collections
purposes one of the details I find fast
I found fascinating on this on this
subject was that the CIA sent one of its
scientists to though this is in 1953 to
one of the largest mushroom growers in
America made a secret deal with them and
said you know and the plan was didn't
reveal to the mushroom grower but that
we were gonna find these hallucinogenic
mushrooms in Mexico and then bring them
back to the United States and farm them
and do all these and you know the volume
of the experiments that the CIA intended
seemed pretty significant based on these
documents but of course the program the
scientist who led this mission he was a
all things a banker from JP Morgan named
Wasson and he Hebrew after he came back
from Mexico with these hallucinogenic
mushrooms he wrote a huge magazine
article about it with in Time magazine
and blew the cover on the program so the
CIA's mushroom program fell by the
wayside it seems that when you start
pulling a thread in in in one of your
stories or in one topic you're
researching all of a sudden there's a
hundred threads that you have to pull
out here and you must be careful of the
rabbit hole because you do go down a lot
of tunnels and I think also it's
important to realize that some of these
programs dead-end and they really do
dead-end or they end
others have different incantations or
get rebooted and rebranded like the
psychic programs of today Annie Jacobson
has four books out area 51 and
uncensored history of America's top
military base came out in 2011 Operation
Paperclip the secret intelligence
program that brought Nazi scientists to
America 2014 the Pentagon's brain a
finalist for the Pulitzer an uncensored
history of DARPA America's top secret
military research agency came out in
2015 and phenomena is her newest the
secret history of the US government's
investigations into extrasensory
perception and psychokinesis and dr.
Martin Jacobson any relation to you I'm
cured ml I'm curious about her approach
to writing how does she get so much done
for books in six years is an amazing
achievement especially given the
difficulty she has mentioned with some
of her sources
how does she schedule her work what
advice she might offer to other writers
thank you for that question
that's one that's near and dear to my
heart which has to do with process it
also has to do with early failure let's
say you know a theme I'm interested in
meaning I've been writing for a very
long time since I was 15
went to boarding school with the
typewriter and no one was really reading
what I was writing for decades and so
the fact now that I have the great
privilege of having people read me
inspires me to keep at it and to keep
writing and I and I encourage anyone who
is writing to continue you know to sort
of follow that idea because I think the
only failure is quitting so if you just
keep at it
you know how do I schedule my writing I
mean I write full-time and I'm always
thinking about the what I'm writing and
why I'm writing it and looking at what's
happening in the current climate of the
world and trying to balance out what are
the concerns that we want to be thinking
about today and filtering that back to
where did a lot of these problems come
from and where are the solutions
I love the Eisenhower idea in his
farewell speech he spoke of the
military-industrial complex that is so
famous but what often gets left out of
that is what he said in the second part
of that speech where he talked about an
alert and knowledgeable citizenry and he
said that that is how you balance
security and liberty what a simple idea
just being alert and knowledgeable and
that's how I approach all of my books I
try to be alert read a lot to be
knowledgeable and then I get to go out
and interview the people who are on the
ground doing the hard work and tell
their stories in my book so that other
can read them all right each of your
books is built in a sense on the last
one what's the next one what's your next
topic I always hate to talk about the
next topic but I'm actually not going to
talk about but you do have another one
from what you've absolutely right I mean
I'm gonna hint at it I'm writing about
the CIA and I I'm it's a really
interesting news story do you write at
home and do you write offline is the
computer you use not connected oh I most
definitely write at home I have an
office I live in Los Angeles and I have
an office kind of you know through the
garden I take a little garden pathway
and that's my office out there
freestanding and it's small enough not
to be distracted these are connected to
the Internet
well my computer is most definitely
connected to the Internet but grissom
we've talked to John Grisham before and
he writes on an offline computer yeah I
mean I'm able to kind of not look at the
internet all the time but it is a huge
source for me but I also do a lot of
writing longhand certainly that's how I
begin my chapters because I find the
brain the human brain no matter how much
technology we have around it works at
its at its own speed at least mine does
and so for me the the process of writing
kind of is like similar to my thought
processes so once I have information and
I know how to begin a chapter I write it
out longhand usually the first couple
pages are always written that way do you
still write poetry sometimes all your
books are dedicated to Kevin who is
Kevin yeah Kevin's my husband the new
book is dedicated to Kevin jet and
Finley my children look the the the joy
of writing is so that I get to hang out
with my family I mean they're a super
source of in for inspiration for me
because you know that has to do with the
quality of life right so if you enjoy
your life if you if you love who you're
with then you are inspired I think to do
interesting and challenging things what
kind of work does your husband do my
husband is a commercial actor has been
forever he's been in every commercial
you can imagine such as you name it
where would we see him milk cars beer I
think we have some b-roll of him in a
car commercial here it's a first
commercial ever shown on c-span I think
but he's in the in the Nissan Pathfinder
commercial and he does that full-time
yes yes yeah does he enjoy it he does I
mean we're both entrepreneurs and you
know in this world we live in where
you're creative and entrepreneurial and
thoughtful even I don't think we've seen
him yet this is the Noah's Ark there he
is sitting driving a bunch of animals
around so and that's your husband that's
my husband long have you been together
we've been married for coming up on 21
years
well Annie Jacobson is our guest and we
are going to continue our conversation
in just a minute after we look at some
of the things that have influenced her
and some of her favorite writers
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country on April 8th look for us to be
live at the Annapolis Book Festival with
author discussions on topics including
politics income inequality and criminal
injustice
also that day we'll be taping author
talks at the San Antonio Book Festival
two weeks later book TV will be live
from the Los Angeles Times Festival of
Books on the campus of the University of
Southern California and on May 20th will
be live from the Gaithersburg Book
Festival in Maryland just north of
Washington DC for more information about
the book fairs and festivals book TV
will be covering and to watch previous
festival coverage click on the Book
Fairs tab on our website book TV org
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
book TV tapes hundreds of author
programs throughout the country all year
long here's a look at some of the events
we'll be covering this week Monday will
be in the nation's capital at Busboys
and poets were former policy advisor and
speechwriter for President Bill Clinton
Eric Liu will share his strategies on
how citizens can become empowered
Tuesday were back in Washington at the
Brookings Institution for Vanessa
Williamson's talked on Americans
attitudes towards taxes also that
evening will be in Fort Myers Florida to
hear former Florida congressman Trey
Radel discuss what led him to resign
from the US House of Representatives
Wednesday were off to the Kansas City
Public Library where David Nichols will
talk about President Dwight Eisenhower's
underground campaign against Senator
Joseph McCarthy that same night will be
at the Thurber house in Columbus Ohio
for former CIA officer nicholas reynolds
talked on ernest hemingway's connections
to Soviet and US intelligence services
and next Saturday will be live at the
15th annual Annapolis Book Festival in
Maryland State Capitol with discussions
on criminal justice income inequality
and terrorism and intelligence featuring
former director of the CIA and the
National Security Agency Michael Hayden
that's a look at some of the programs
spoke TV we'll be covering this week
many of these events are open to the
public look for them to air in the near
future on book TV on c-span too
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals happening around the
country on April 8th look for us to be
live at the Annapolis Book Festival with
author discussions on topics including
politics income inequality and criminal
injustice
also that day we'll be taping author
talks at the San Antonio Book Festival
two weeks later
book TV will be live from the Los
Angeles Times Festival of Books on the
campus of the University of Southern
California and on May 20th will be live
from the Gaithersburg Book Festival in
Maryland just north of Washington DC for
more information about the book fairs
and festivals book TV will be covering
and to watch previous festival coverage
click on the Book Fairs tab on our
website book tv.org
Annie Jacobson you say that you are
reading or have read the lost city of
the monkey god by Douglas Preston what
is that it's a book about an
archeological quest I mean I love quest
stories I think that they're part and
parcel to human nature they always bring
in the idea of success and failure and
then also this idea of who are we and
where did we come from I mean the more
we learn about the past I think it gives
us ideas about the future about where
we're going which takes me back to
phenomena the reaches of what can be
known I'm always fascinated when we have
this this is the way the world was and
then Oh archaeology reveals actually it
was a little different do you think
DARPA new cell phone technology 30 years
ago was going to be our 40 or 50 years
ago when it was first founded that's a
great question I mean I think maybe it
goes all the way back to John von
Neumann who I write about in the
Pentagon's brain I call him the original
Pentagon's brain and he was kind of the
inventor of the first computer that
contained its own instructions he were
talking in the 1940s now in the basement
of the Princeton Institute for Advanced
Study where Einstein was von Neumann
created this computer he called the
maniac it was essentially like a giant
calculator but what was interesting so
when you asked like where are we now I
go back to that because of for this
reason this is an amazing anecdote von
Neumann was so smart I mean he was a
polymath and he built this computer and
originally were like in 1947 now he
would his assistants
he would try to beat the computer at a
numerical calculation and his assistants
would feed him the calculations and he
would compute them in his brain and he
was able to beat the computer originally
and then one day in the late 1940s the
computer beat von Neumann and really
it's this profound moment
and right then and there von Oy Minh
said that he believed that one day
computers would be able to think that
idea of sentience so that's like really
looking far off and and what we have
today in the in the smartphone you know
pulls back to that origin story I mean
in the smartphone iPhones first
generation smartphone had more
technology than Nassau had more computer
technology the Nassau had when it sent
ed Mitchell to the moon think about that
who's thinking about the future
certainly someone like John von Neumann
certainly almost all of the scientists
that DARPA employs john von neumann vana
Vere Bush men of our Bush JCR Licklider
and these are not names that we know
today Licklider again he's the these
called the Johnny Appleseed of the
internet because he did plant the first
seeds
he was a DARPA scientist called upon to
in the JFK era to do something about
what's called situ in military jingo
command and control okay so think of
technology we're talking about the
iPhone go back to 1962 JFK looking at a
red phone right the red phone that's the
phone that if you think there's a
nuclear strike you have to call
Khrushchev okay and that technique about
the the dialing capacity on a rotary
phone and DARPA was brought on board to
try and speed that up using computers I
mean at the time computers were the size
of a room so Licklider was brought in to
speed up this c2 process and while he
was working on those programs there at
the Pentagon he came up with this idea
he sent out this very famous memo among
computer technologists which was this
where he came up with this idea that one
day people would be able to communicate
via computers I mean he was really
talking about the Internet in his mind
but he called it the intergalactic
computer network and it was going to be
this symbiotic relationship between man
machine he planted those original seeds
for the ARPANET he left and many capable
people took over and built the Internet
and then you have this today linking up
to that technology in our phones so what
man is capable of thinking about is
astonishing what are the reaches of what
we can know what will we know next
you're also reading Neil Gaiman's
Norse mythology yes well that has to do
my husband's Norwegian so my kids are
Norwegian and also you know I love myths
I mean I love the idea of storytelling I
love archetypes Carl Jung plays a role
in my new book phenomena for that reason
the archetypes of the unconscious of the
unconscious you know these are basic
tenants of narrative storytelling and
they're also basic tenants I think of
how people live their lives how they
strive what they strive for do they want
to be the hero you know that's an
archetype that's part of mythology 2:02
is the area code if you want to talk
with our guest Andy Jacobson this
afternoon 7 for 8 80 200 for those in
the East and Central time zones seven
four eight eight two zero one for those
of you in the mountain and Pacific time
zones will also scroll through some of
our social media sites and that way you
can also make a comment via social media
July 9th 1947 Roswell New Mexico what
happened you love I'm thinking that
maybe at home you're googling some of
these conspiracy theories probably she
more than a go ah interesting
look the myth of Roswell is part and
parcel to certainly to area 51 certainly
to the idea that the government keeps
secrets that the military keep secrets
that is when allegedly a UFO crashed and
the military stepped in and you know
took the evidence away it links up to
area 51 as I
said because this source of mine told me
that he was part of the team that years
later received the what crashed at
Roswell at area 51 and this is where
this is the origin story of the alien
method of area 51 well when you read
your accounting of July 9 1947 in area
51
it's very believable tell me what you
tell me what you've I mean everyone has
a different interpretation of it so this
is perspective POV tell me yours well
you talk about the fact that there were
there was a bulletin sent out mm-hmm
that the Air Force sent out a bulletin
or put it on the news that this was
found and then they an hour later they
came back and had another bulletin and
that there were 47 witnesses to this
whole thing
98 witnesses to this whole thing trucks
being loaded child coffins etc etc these
are documented facts and you know I mean
like the JFK conspiracy there are
numerous people we can't even put a
number on it that spend so much time
going over the precise details I go over
them broadly but you mentioned the most
important ones that are and I think
there when I say the most important
because they are actually what we would
call fact checkable you know and when
you have big mysteries and considerable
discrepancies within the fact checkable
information I think it's fair to raise
questions about what actually went on
and why are you covering this up because
there is a cover-up if you're gonna
change your story
lose in Conroe Texas go ahead Lou yes
good afternoon miss Jacobson fascinating
two questions one did you do any reviews
of the violet Ludlum's books
born I got any series for any of your
writings and to do you think the current
election of the president with all those
military in the cabinet and
the defense spending do you think that's
a dark CIA project thank you I'm not
familiar with any of the caller's books
that he talked about Robert Ludlum yes
but I tend to read more nonfiction than
fiction but as for the current
administration I attempt to stay out of
politics and this is why is because I
think it's more valuable to maintain
neutrality in terms of political systems
agendas etc because I'm reporting on the
intelligence community in the Defense
Department and that doesn't change I
mean the leader the commander in chief
changes but many of those individuals
are entrenched and I know and work with
many people on both sides of the aisle
and I see their point I see both sides
of the aisles points so I'm more
interested in the battle I'm more
interested in the individual quest and
I'm most interested in the outcome
well given and let's go to Operation
Paperclip for this but in all of your
books I think you can find this have we
morally compromised ourselves as a
nation at times for goals do as you ask
do the ends justify the means
well that's a perfect question segwayed
into the previous question and here is
why when I was working on paperclip my
editor and I would have conversations
about making sure that I was showing
both sides of the argument okay and if
there was any book that I was prone to
having an opinion about it was Operation
Paperclip okay and I'm not Jewish by the
way right because of my last name many
people she's gonna side with the you
know but what was what was interesting
to me is that
I did try to maintain that neutrality
and I think I may have succeeded in
here's why because I tried to show also
why there was an argument that it was
important to bring the Nazi scientists
here to beat back the Russians
so was it a moral compromise I'm telling
you here on book TV that in my opinion
yes it felt that way when I was writing
it my job as a journalist was to say
show both says Dale I was on one
television program that leans right
let's say and they said Annie I'm so
glad you wrote this book
you showed part-and-parcel why we had to
have this program we had to have it yes
the Nazis were terrible but we needed to
bring them here because we had to win
the Cold War I could be on another show
that would lean left and they would say
Annie thank you for writing this book
you show that this was morally
reprehensible
we absolutely never ever should have
brought these Nazis here no matter what
you show it person parcel thank you they
read the same book which speaks to my
curiosity about perspective about what
how people interpret the same facts and
that is part of human nature the the the
ability that we have to see things our
way I think where things get really
interesting is when you have some would
call it a change of heart others would
call it a change of mind
that's what interested me in phenomena
in particular because almost everyone
who works in that world has what's
called a conversion moment where they
have a change of heart where they have a
change of mind their life changes and
the results are dramatic I think I
remember reading an Operation Paperclip
Wernher von Braun he had a conversion
but it was a he was born again as a
Christian yes yes and again because I
mean I didn't interview him and I didn't
interview any of his family members it's
hard to really know
the reality behind that and I mean the
the motivations let's say because
there's no way of knowing if it was
personally motivated like from the heart
or whether it was a motivation from his
handlers at Nassau who said listen if
you pull some good old you know religion
into the mix here you're going to be
more appealing to the average American
than the former
you know Nazi scientists with a strong
German accent does this tie in at all to
the the project over in Switzerland in
France the big you know bang yeah yeah
does it tie in at all some of the
research that DARPA is doing not that I
know of but you know I wouldn't doubt it
because all of this science is
interconnected in an interesting way and
we in the in America the the defense
scientists are always looking at what's
happening around the world going back to
that theme that we cannot be beaten
we cannot be overtaken by technological
surprise that's what happened with
Sputnik in 1958 they made it into space
before we did and that has never
happened since so there is good reason
to say wow DARPA is doing its job email
and this is from Jim do you have any
knowledge of soldiers being experimented
on during the Vietnam War era with drugs
like LSD also using testing them with
ESP or UFOs etc human testing is an
infinitely interesting and problematic
area in Operation Paperclip I write
about the origins of the nürnberg code
and then in area 51 I write about how
the Nuremberg code was defied by our
scientists working for the Atomic Energy
Commission conducting human experiments
related to radiation really nefarious
experiments that were made transparent
by the Clinton
administration these are worthy
documents very important to look at
because it shows you what is possible
right what is possible flying in the
face of something like the nürnberg code
I'm always on the lookout for that kind
of work for those kind of operations
programs I did not find any that the
reader is specifically referring to Dave
Cleveland Ohio good afternoon Annie
Jacobson is our guest thank you for
taking my call and thank you for book TV
my question is concerning 1957 that was
the year of Sputnik and also wasan life
article with the multi-color photographs
appeared in 57 and in april of 57 they
had project 57 it occurred right before
the nuclear test series operation
plumb-bob
and in project 57 this was near area 51
plutonium was scattered across the
desert and I wonder if your research in
the area 51 if you can give us any more
details about project 57 that might be
of interest Dave do you have a wide the
interest in these topics
well back in 1989 I was delivering mail
and met a man who had been in Hiroshima
u.s. army guy I saw a TV show about
cloud samplers and I also started
getting a lot of newspaper photographs
relating to the nuclear test series I
was able to tour the test site in 1995
and III have quite a lot of documents
I've got from the government at one time
I was at the Reynolds electrical and
engineering public reading room down
there in Las Vegas and I actually had in
my hands uncensored documents I saw the
names and the rates of dose that cloud
samplers were getting that was quite a
thrilling day so I'm wondering in
particular about project 57 thank you
sir
I write about project 57 at length in
area 51 and it was a fascinating test
because we did do that plutonium
dispersal and I tell it through the
perspective
the security guard out there at the time
a man by the name of Richard Mingus and
it's extraordinary what went on the kind
of fast and loose operations that the
AEC was conducting I also write about
cloud sampling because that is part and
parcel to this because many of the test
pilots who I interviewed for area 51
including the great Hervey Stockman who
is the first man to fly over the Soviet
Union in a u2 this is in 1956 bringing
home photographs of 400,000 square feet
of the Soviet Union that had been unseen
by the intelligence community before
Stockman then went on and was a was a
nuclear test pilot and flew directly
through some of those clouds that are
being discussed here so again they this
all kind of loops around together the
different threads come out in different
ways and the u2 was developed at area 51
is interested that was the CIA's first
spy plane program they called it eyes in
the spy eyes in the sky and it was to
the u2 and then when the u2 you know so
much of this is about we do this and
then the Soviets would beat us or
Soviets would beat us back right so we
built the you tube to fly high enough
that would be out of range of Soviet
surface-to-air missiles well then they
built up their surface-to-air missile
suddenly you have the Gary Powers
incident gets shot down so the CIA
starts building this new airplane that
we talked about called the oxcart and
that was this incredibly super-secret
project at area 51 many of the same
scientists edward Lovick who gave me my
original scoop worked on the u2 then
worked on oxcart would it surprise you
today if Congress or the Vice President
weren't aware of some of the things that
are going on or even the president I
wrote that in I found that out much to
my astonishment when I was writing area
51 and I was talking to a source about
this incredibly secret program that
it allegedly evolved human you know
experiments out there the crossover with
the aliens and I said how come this was
not uncovered during the Clinton
administration when so much of this that
these nefarious human experiments out of
the test site became public and the
source said the president did not have a
need to know that is an interesting
statement Roy Newcastle Indiana please
go ahead yes
kudos to c-span and you Peter
and to Anna Dickenson
and I just have a little question here
I've talked with Carol rosin that was
there for a while right arm to von Braun
in his latter days and I've communicated
her the sky bmail and talking with her
and I just wonder if you know anything
anything about her whereabouts and if
she's still involved with dr. Steven
Greer and the such continue I don't I I
don't do any of those names ring a bell
besides von braun's nope
where did he end up von braun yeah he
worked in the defense contracting
industry but from my read on documents
about him from the government is that
you know after the apollo program ended
so abruptly it was extraordinary
distressing to him I mean where do you
go from there he was it was such a high
to be the kind of most famous scientist
in the country during the Apollo era and
then you know people gave up on that
program very difficult time Vietnam War
and von Braun sort of the way I read it
lost his he lost his way and he became
despondent and I write about that in
paperclip and then he's diagnosed with
with cancer and and he died very very
quickly
Greg Clearwater Florida please go ahead
with your question or comment for Annie
Jacobson yes thanks
taking my call I have a question about
the current state of the art of secret
aircraft technology in the u.s. because
the sr-71 and a12 spy planes were 1950s
technology the f-117 stealth fighter was
1970s technology and the b-2 bomber is
1980s technology that's a long time ago
have you heard about anything about
current state of the art exotic aircraft
being operated by the US and their
capabilities and just a footnote I do
know about the Air Force's x-37b space
plane one of which is still in orbit
after 600 days in space I think you
nailed it with that last program that's
one of the more interesting ones I know
about and I write about it in the
Pentagon's brain the way I would
approach that answer is to say like if
you look back at the technology in the
1960s with the a12 oxcart and you
consider going 2,400 miles an hour then
you know in under these secret programs
you can kind of figure out what must be
going on today based on the the
information that you talked about the
programs that we know about and then you
kind of can you know speculate on what
is unknown and again those programs are
kept secret because they are part and
parcel to national security
I mean the Air has always been important
space to dominate for the Defense
Department from page 364 of phenomena
the UN turned to extrasensory powers to
help it find Saddam Hussein's weapons
sites this gets into the downfall of the
program because you had some of the
soldiers who had been trained to be
psychic retiring from the military and
taking it upon themselves to offer their
services outside the military and that
is that situation you're talking about
now that led to a grave problem because
the proto
calls involved in remote viewing at that
time we're still classified and so by
bringing the this the very subject to
the public that there was a press
release on that because the journalists
found that interesting as they should
and then the kibosh was put on that and
it took a couple more years for the
program to really be revealed but that
was a that was a former soldier going
outside of the military offering private
services to the UN since Robert Lazar in
1989 revealing area 51 to the general
public has there been somebody else who
has done this that's a good question
not specifically related to area 51
certainly the numbers of people
interested in that are phenomenal but
and and yes their revelations all the
time but I think Lazar learned an
interesting you know came to an
interesting conclusion certainly in my
interview with him about what happens if
you reveal something that you're not
supposed to reveal and the Defense
Department learned how to deal with
people who say outlandish things or / or
people who say things that they can spin
as outlandish or you know reflect as
outlandish and so and also keep in mind
when lazier made his declaration I mean
the world was a totally different place
in terms of our smartphones in turn you
know information is king now and you can
learn so many different things in so
many different ways so it doesn't have
the same power that Lazar had going on
ABC TV I mean that was a big deal when
you put in the request to visit area 51
to whom did you put it in and what was
the answer I requested to go home with
Ed Lovick you know I presented it as
wouldn't this be a terrific way to make
transparent to the public and you know
their response
is brilliant I mean it's always true to
form and they and they you know they
they spin around the facts because they
can't actually say I refer to it as
groom lake thinking maybe they would you
know take the bait but they didn't and
of course they just it's like your
request to go somewhere that were can't
even really say exists has been denied
what's area 12 there are all kinds of
areas out at the Nevada Test Site and
they're divided up all of them involve
nuclear testing area 13 was where there
was the plutonium test area 25 was where
they were building a spaceship that was
going to take us to Mars using nuclear
weapons technology I mean you could
write a different book about every one
of those areas out there if you drive
north of Vegas on I believe it's how
state highway 95 you go right past
Nellis Air Force Base or kind of through
it in a sense is that where area 51 is
how far off 95 is area 51 area 51 is
kind of like north in the different
direction because it's inside the test
site but Nellis has always played an
interesting role because they you know
there's stories abound about pilots who
because everybody knows you cannot fly
over area 51 and every now and then
there's kind of like someone puts their
wing into the tip of the box so to speak
and there's kind of a report most of
which is redacted but yes they they work
hand in glove and always have I mean
that part of the country with all these
different classified areas out there if
you look at a map between China Lake in
California and you look at area 51 in
Nevada the test site these are huge
swaths of land where classified military
technology is fully underway when you
requested to visit the headquarters of
DARPA which you describe in in your book
the Pentagon's brain as being in
Arlington Virginia suburb here what was
the response
same thing you know they they really
want to be able to control the message I
think more than anything and the idea is
well if you keep a journalist out you're
definitely controlling the message
because they're not in so that is a
ongoing source of frustration I think
because I do think that there's a
responsibility by government to try and
make the facts known and to try and make
some of these facilities available to
people like myself but what DARPA said
you know which they do have a good point
they are not a laboratory
it's just administration that's going on
there or so they say
so they were saying go you're gonna
you're gonna do better visiting the
actual laboratories and so I did and
there's DARPA headquarters on your
screen does NASA have an official
position on Edgar Mitchell and his turn
towards ESP and psychokinesis you know
they do I don't know of an official
position but you can definitely I could
in reading the documents you could get a
sense of I don't want to say
disappointment but that's the word that
comes to mind you know they like
individuals who are part of their big
programs to stick with the part that
stick with the message so to speak and
you know he had some wild ideas
he became very interested in the idea
about aliens toward the end of his life
and he spoke about it at length and I
think a lot of the you know you kind of
go where the love is right for lack of a
better expression and so he's getting a
lot of let's say even nastiness from
NASA I mean they brought a lawsuit
against him at one point over some
equipment so and he's being embraced by
individuals who lean towards some call
conspiratorial ideas about aliens and he
definitely leaned towards that way and
again it cost him you know but I find
that really interesting what I also
found fascinating was
Michels relationship with regular
because I interview Geller at length and
phenomena and I found him to be
extraordinarily interesting and dynamic
I also wound up at Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu's house when I was
with her Geller in Israel raising
extraordinary questions about whether or
not he works for Mossad which is why he
left the CIA program but you know when I
interviewed Mitchell he spoke so highly
of Geller and when I interviewed Geller
he spoke so highly of Mitchell they were
like foils for one another - Mitchell
curry Geller represented everything that
is possible that idea of the far reaches
of man and and his biological
capabilities and - Geller Mitchell
represented the great Explorer the great
hero because he was young when Mitchell
went to the moon he was in his 20s and
he told me that Edie Mitchell knowing
about Geller's you know telepathy
experiments and his public persona
Mitchell sent him a photograph of
himself on the moon and signed it and
you know said the equivalent of gourry
and Geller said this just made him feel
amazing in these in this moment of doubt
because he was being attacked publicly
by James Randi and every other
scientific skeptic and really dragged
through the mud and he said Mitchell
gave him the kind of you know the
stamina and the energy and the end and
the hopefulness to go forward so they
just have this fascinating friendship
over the decades that I found really
mysterious finished the story about
being at Prime Minister Netanyahu's
house with the uri geller
how did you get there so I mean how did
we get there the quest narrative I was
interviewing Geller in in Israel and I
had specifically wanted to spend a lot
of time with him because I wanted to I
figured that if he was a magician and he
was doing this act by pre digitation
what you know Randi and other
do magicians can bend spoons by just you
know the a trick I figured if I spend
enough time with Geller I might be able
to see you know a crack in the veil so
to speak which I never saw I mean I was
with him for several days for like eight
and ten hours a day walking all over Tel
Aviv and everywhere we went
I mean he's so famous he's the most
famous person in Israel it seems like
and everyone asked him to bend a spoon
and he did and you know I mean these
remarkable circumstances and big soup
spoons and a kitchen once in the in a
restaurant I mean it was really and you
saw that huh
I saw it happen I mean it was just you
know and he doesn't really necessarily
touch the spoon that's what I found
fascinating
I saw him bend a pair of hookah tongs
for two North Africans who were there
and you know hookah tongs are crafted to
withstand extraordinary heat and and he
did that you know the hookah tongs are
like this and he kind of held his finger
it was remarkable but the one situation
I was curious about and I wasn't I told
him I wasn't really buying was this idea
that he worked for the Mossad because he
told me that when he was a little boy
that had been his dream so I wondered
going back to this archetype the idea of
young right oh maybe this is his kind of
childhood fantasy and I said that to him
I'm not buying it and what would the
Mossad need you for the spoon bender and
he got angry with me and you know he has
a very big ego by his own admittance and
then a few hours later we rock up to the
residence of the Prime Minister and what
was amazing is everybody knew early
Geller I mean the the agents the
protective detail hey you know we event
a spoon for us and he was bending spoons
and it just had this very surreal
quality to it of like there is something
going on here that's outside the scope
of you know the journalists need to know
and I found it really fascinating and
then of course we were sitting there in
the residence and then Gellar
disappeared into the back and I wondered
is this how the
Mossad works I don't know it's it's a
mystery so it makes you more of a sheep
than a go it makes me more of a sheep
than a goat you know I mean that kind of
experience but really it makes me open
to the idea I mean that's what smilar
said and those that scale it's like I'm
open to the idea because I'm open to the
idea of it's a quest to determine the
not the REE you know to think about and
and what can be known what is man
capable of and if you think of the world
we live in now and this astonishing rate
of Technology you know young said it
where when he and the Nobel laureate
physicists Wolfgang Pauli were
discussing ESP they had a decade's long
debate ESP is it fact or fantasy and
Jung said you can only judge what is
possible by the criteria of the age
right so think about what we've been
talking about this for hours now where
we are now with computer technology I
mean where we are with space travel this
was the this was science fiction decades
ago and now it's all possible so if you
allow yourself to hold that idea and not
be so judgemental against these idea
that yes for millennium have been you
know aligned with the supernatural have
been aligned with magic but if you can
just hold the idea and think about it I
think there is more to be revealed dawn
Houston Texas
Andy Jacobson is our guest thank you for
taking my call I was in the Air Force
for eight years and I was in Edinburgh
when I was those years and some things
happened at Battenberg I worked with
NASA and with the 43rd 92nd half water
and I met I met Carl Sagan
I also met the colonel that was over a
project Bluebook and there was rumors
that and I saw number officers landed on
a private aircraft we were told they
were majestic 12 people and a few days
before just gathering of VIPs we want to
call them early afternoons three UFOs
passed over base and all the PAR went
out for about 15-20 minutes it was a
census it was a sac base we had missile
silos but we weren't a nuclear-armed
missile base they transpired missiles
that would be used if we did go to war
with Russia
don did you actually see the UFOs
yourself yes I was I was at Dawg site
when when they passed over and my work
part of Sergeant Miceli was outside silo
and other people were standing in the
area these air police were out there
when were they passed they didn't pass
they they came fashion and they came to
a stop and I remember I looked at by
charity kind of looked at me and I I
said look I'm not saying what I'm saying
or what and he kind of laughed he said
I'm not sure but he said you know I
don't think we want of anything in our
in our industry that can do these kind
of things Burk and I said well you know
I said I think you're right and then
they dangled off write it on my rate of
speed and then they came back about
three or four minutes later and it over
right over the missile silo sites and
then they headed out towards where the
NASA launch you see was communication
satellites and then sometimes it was top
secret operations that then I guess they
were launching whatever play the
military
and are you are you convinced on that
these were UFOs well before this
happened okay III mean I walked a fence
I didn't say yeah we're not alone yeah
we are alone but I'm an Irish Catholic
and I I told a person one day I'd be
ashamed if you know the God that created
the universe put us out here by
ourselves so evolved alright done thank
you let's hear from Annie Jacobson on
this or did you have a question for him
so UFO unidentified flying object I
write about this at length an area 51
unidentified flying object there are two
sides of the aisle those who say they
come from another galaxy let's say and
those who say they are unidentified
flying aircraft meaning they are still
classified projects and one thing I can
tell you for certain is that UFOs were
part and parcel to the early days of
area 51 because the u2 was often
mistaken for a UFO the oxcart was often
mistaken for a UFO and I interviewed the
pilots and the scientists who were
working on this and the officials from
the government who were in charge of
putting the kibosh on those reports
sometimes people who saw them and again
what they were seeing was the oxcart
okay and they would see this shiny
object going at a speed that wasn't
humanly possible because 2,400 miles an
hour was an unknown speed to be able to
fly in the early 1960s so the FBI would
knock at the door and you know literally
pay a visit to the people who reported
these to let them know that they didn't
see anything strange and that created
its own new conspiracy because if the
FBI shows up at your door and tells them
you didn't see something that you know
you saw now that's not to completely
disregard all of those individuals who
firmly believe they have seen things in
the skies that cannot be explained I
just think there are different sides of
the argument
all your books have been bestsellers
does that surprise you someone who spent
decades trying to get someone to read
what I was writing yes that surprises me
it's the best kind of surprise why'd you
give up on the Great American Novel no
one was buying the Great and not the
Great American Novel from Annie Jacobson
you know I mean I think it's important
to sort of pivot to where the where the
work is you know and when I say work I
mean you know employment when I became a
reporter that really changed things for
me because I was able to accept that so
much of writing at least for me is craft
you know it's just stay at it and keep
at it and ultimately you will find and
narrate the story a couple of your books
are in the the movie mode aren't they
yes yes it's actually just artists all
of them they all are I mean they're
actually in television development and
my new book phenomena was just optioned
by Steven Spielberg's Amblin and jason
blum blum house so it's amazing because
you have sort of the old guard you know
et right and Close Encounters I mean
let's face it Spielberg built this genre
in the fictional world well in the
modern fictional world and then you have
Blum house who are responsible for not
only the horror genre becoming so
popular they do all the paranormal
activities but they also make really
interesting movies like whiplash
documentaries like the jinx and that
those projects are all about what makes
you uncomfortable and I think in dealing
with phenomena this squishy science idea
this idea that's the center of a battle
between the skeptics and the
supernaturalists
it makes people really uncomfortable
because you know they think one thing
and then they talk to the other side and
they think that thing I mean I find that
super interesting because we have to
ultimately you know come to terms with
our own beliefs in beliefs set but a lot
of times it's a process the amazing
thing about film and tell
they're sort of the gentle way in to
many of these subjects and they spark an
interest in the nonfiction world I think
they work part and parcel okay explain
Hollywood here
you said phenomena has been optioned by
both Spielberg and by Blum how is it
that two people can option the same
problem well they team up so they're
like two great teams and then the
content is created of how to move
forward I mean you see that Operation
Paperclip is in development with Brad
Pitt's company which is called Plan B
and Rat Pack which is Brett Ratner's
company and they they team up so a lot
of times you have and and pentagons
brain you have JJ Abrams bad robot the
people behind Star Wars working with
Warner Brothers so an area 51 AMC you
know with Gale and heard the woman who
co-wrote The Terminator
but again I think these these science
fiction is super interesting to a lot of
people for my favorite theme the reaches
of what can be known so much of science
fiction winds up becoming the truth and
in fact so many scientists famous
scientists Nobel laureates tell me that
their ideas come from reading science
fiction as a child
well George Orwell was one of your
influences that you just did why I mean
you know that idea of what the future
may be like is very interesting to me
and and I like cautionary tales because
you can see what you want to avoid or
what you hope to avoid you know the idea
of dystopia is a spooky one particular
and particularly important this speaks
to the pentagon's brain the last
chapters in the Pentagon's brain I wrote
about DARPA Square synthetic brain you
know and my visit out to Los Alamos to
meet with those scientists who are
working on that
we'll artificial-intelligence lead us to
a place that you know George Orwell
would have written about or did write
about or will it liberate us you know
it's that it's that Eisenhower question
I mean how do security and liberty live
side-by-side and now that artificial
intelligence is such a major player
everywhere you know the quest for it
because of course we have whether or not
we will achieve true sentience and
machines with something von Neumann
predicted but we have yet to know but
the Defense Department is certainly
moving in the direction of marrying
autonomous weapons drones with
artificial intelligence I see danger in
that I see the cautionary tale Marcia
Union bridge Maryland email were you
ever threatened because of the research
you did for your books do you know if
you've ever been under surveillance
because of your books
look the capabilities of the government
are extensive you know in terms of
surveillance and I write about that in
all of my books I just really keep my
nose clean meaning I'm just after the
facts and I talk to scientists who
worked on very secret very classified
military programs and they are aware of
what they can say and what they cannot
say and that's really where the risk is
so I'm just I mean I'm very grateful
that scientists agree to talk to me
because it would perhaps be easier to
say I can't because they're the ones
that I have to tow that line and you
know keep these ideas in their mind okay
I can talk about that program and I
can't talk about that because you cannot
disclosed classified information period
and that's the risk that they take which
is a far greater risk I think than me as
a reporter writing narrative nonfiction
Jeanne and Hillsboro North Carolina good
afternoon to you
hi I wonder if you could maybe confirm
or if you say whether you've ever heard
about this rumor that was running around
at one technology company I work for a
long time ago and that is Special Forces
Delta and sales get a chip embedded for
identification purposes like after the
failed Iranian hostage attempt they they
got remains back and after that they
decided they needed to do the to put
chips into those guys so they can maybe
identify remains easier thank you sir
the chipping technology is very
controversial I mean yes there's the
chips in the body for identification
purposes I mean civilians do that as
well so but there's also the chip in the
brain programs that I write about in the
Pentagon's brain that I think are far
more of concern and again they're
they're presented by DARPA under the
rubric of warrior wellness under this
idea that brain wounded soldiers can you
know have a chip in their brain and it
can they can work on these programs to
you know and bring back some cognition
but this is a very slippery slope area
and even the Jason scientists who I
interviewed advise the Pentagon not to
go in that direction for fear of and
this was an exact quote it could lean to
it could lead to you know high-quality
brain control and when you have a again
that cautionary tale idea when you have
a warning from a group of scientists who
have been advising the Pentagon for
decades and the Pentagon chooses to
ignore that I think it's important that
those facts be known and then the
citizenry can decide whether or not they
think this is a good idea putting chips
anywhere in people's bodies but on the
flipside then what if the Russians what
if the Chinese are working on this and
we don't want to be caught
technologically surprised and that's
always the argument so you really have
to say
who's pushing the science where and why
right and yes DARPA is is absolutely you
know on the cutting edge of all these
technologies but the Russians also have
a DARPA and so does so do the Chinese
Paul Huntington Beach California Annie
Jacobson is our guest we have about 15
minutes left
thank you very much for putting me on I
have a number of questions the first
question is Bob Lazar and I'm sure
you've discussed Bob Lazar the
interesting thing is that by coincidence
Lazar was Hungarian and apparently dr.
teller recommended that he work on the
reverse engineering of alien craft so I
wonder if you've already discussed that
or whether you'd like to discuss it item
number two I visited wright-patterson
Air Force Base last year and of course
the Roswell incident involved is a
removal of debris initially to a special
hangar then wright-patterson Air Force
Base and I think from there was spirited
away to area 51 and unfortunately I
haven't had the opportunity to read your
books but I will because I'm a neighbor
so that's another area the third area
that is fascinating is that back in the
90s a an American military gentleman a
colonel published a book in which he
theorized based on his experience and
proposed the fact that alien craft and
alien reverse engineering was largely
responsible for the explosion of
technological breakthroughs that took
place in the fifties and that many of
those breakthroughs were done by DARPA
and then disseminate
through the private sector
tell you what Paul we'll leave it at
those three questions but very quickly
do you believe that on your third
question it's it's hard to disprove
because the explosion if you take a look
at the development of human civilization
there are timelines when major
discoveries are made Archimedes
Aristotle the Euclidian theorem you've
got Isaac Newton but a huge
concentration in a thirty decade period
of explosive discoveries simply is
statistically out of the norm of human
evolution at least I certainly feel it
is because we're looking at computing
we're looking at bioengineering we're
looking at the discovery of the
transistor we're looking at the
tremendous proliferation of the use of
silicon and the additional electronic
discoveries but in particular kelly
johnson skunkworks
and i'm sure you're familiar with skunk
works the aerodynamics that emerged out
of the skunk works and subsequently are
so radically different from the previous
history of aerodynamics in particular to
sharp aerodynamic edges of the u2
Wranglers paul thank you for that and i
apologize i think we got the gist so
many of these subjects are covered in
area 51 and you know from Lockheed
teller Lazar again these are all ideas
if you think about going back to what we
were just talking about what is possible
in any age okay the idea of strange
things in the sky has been an issue that
people have thought about and
contemplate
and created art about going back to pre
civilization I visited the British
Museum while I was writing the phenomena
and looked at these the earliest
examples of what people thought were
UFOs I looked at June a áformer items
from King Ashburn open all's library
omens divination rulers back in 600 BC
would say who will win the war you know
I went to the Oracle at Delphi to kind
of read and feel what it was like to
work with prophecy so prophecy UFOs man
civilisation biology what is possible
these are all part and parcel to all the
subjects I investigate and I just love
the fact that there are ideas that exist
and we look as journalists we go into
the documentation we interview people we
present the stories as best I present
the stories that I do in my books as
best as I can based on eyewitnesses
based on documentation and based on the
work of other journalists before me who
have laid the tracks down and so the
story is always evolving and changing
and transforming but ultimately it's
going in that direction about you know
what do we know about the past and how
can we use that as we move forward in
the future and make sense of this world
that we live in where technology is
advancing at this astonishing rate and
yet we and our ideas our brains are
still relatively the same what about his
point that all of a sudden we had these
great technological leaps beginning in
the fifties well many scientists talk
about that idea of knowledge kind of the
same discoveries cropping up in
different parts of the world at the same
time and and that is super interesting I
mean one of the themes that I write
about in phenomena that I did not that
that is new to my sort of you know works
if you will
speaks a little bit to the readers
question and to your point and it has to
do with this idea of where does
inspiration come from
okay the eureka moment and i'll tell a
story about the great charles towns and
what he told me in our interview now
Charles towns won the Nobel Prize in
1919 60s for the laser okay
arguably one of the most important
technological inventions of the modern
era
I mean military applications laser
weapons civilian use eye surgery the
laser printer and I bring this up
because the scientific skeptics always
go crazy on this idea and on balance
when you think that the idea I'm about
to tell you comes from Charles Townes ok
it kind of puts things in perspective so
I asked him to confirm with me a kind of
story that was out there about him that
the idea of the laser came to him while
he was sitting on a park bench and he
said yes that is right that was his
Eureka moment now Townes we learn is a
man of faith
so that Eureka moment to him in his view
of the world and in his perspective was
something that came to him from the
supernatural ok
and this I think speaks to the callers
questions about where are these ideas
coming from and some people the sheep
will tell you that great moments are not
limited to you know I came up with this
idea myself sitting at my desk
they often there are three Nobel
laureates I write in the book who all
talk about these Eureka moments and who
believed that these ideas come from
without and I think the whole world and
the narratives of aliens and higher
intelligence maybe even consciousness
that is touching upon that theory that
there is a greater intelligence out
there and I think that it it's not I
don't think it's unwise for me anyways
to dismiss this whole cloth to take the
position of the goat and essentially
ridicule it I think the idea of being
open to it is far more interesting in
far more courageous dick Troy Alabama
you're on book TV c-span thank you very
much for the last two two hours and 50
minutes this has been absolutely
captivating miss miss Dickinson I have a
question but first of all I'd like to
tell you you just sold books because I'm
a bomb tomorrow but I would like to know
though you you make this quotation twice
by tributing the eyes now and there's a
tear will speak the amounts between
security and liberty is an informed
public I won't know this
and please don't consider this to be a
lean question because I don't mean for
it to be but just how much should we
know about what's going on and we'll get
an answer in two seconds
dick will you just tell us a little bit
about yourself I kind of be a writer but
not very wise my knowledge is very
shallow I really I don't even know
shallow would be the proper word about
what you're talking what kind of work
did you do
are you retired top student for a while
but I've been a lot of other things too
but most enjoyable show and I wish you
would write a novel mrs. Jacobson there
we go thank you so much how much should
we know another theme that I'm always
writing about because when you see some
of the program's Declassified and you
realize what was that issue what was at
stake there is very good reason in men
instances to keep those programs
classified so that the other side
doesn't isn't aware of that and then it
remains a true defensive measure there
lies the conundrum of the
military-industrial complex and I think
you're the caller's question is actually
brilliant because the
military-industrial complex exists for a
purpose for national security but if
they're if their goal is to speed up the
revelations then you also have what one
Defense Department official described me
as a self licking ice cream cone right
so in other words if you could have a
great weapon system that that stayed
classified the end the other
intelligence community on the other side
knew about it and couldn't defend
against it and the goal was to keep us
keep that the two powers in check then
essentially you have an effective weapon
system but the minute that system
becomes known like the you know the
f-117 then that becomes obsolete and it
creates an entire new vacuum ie new
business for the defense contractors to
create a new weapon system so it's it's
a brilliant question and I think it's
there is no easy answer but the the
investigation the investigator in me is
infinitely interested in in pursuing
that thought and finding out what I can
and presenting those facts to the public
this is an email from Joe which one or
two programs would you like to see
release to the public tomorrow which one
or to wake you up in a cold way I mean
that's a great question but I'd you know
I don't know because I think the old
really and truly the the unknowable
programs are the most interesting and it
never ceases to amaze me when you learn
about a program that you know no one
knew about before that then you really
know the government's doing its job of
keeping things secret but if I had to
say looking back
I think the weapons test that we did in
space are extremely interesting and I
would like I know that a lot of those
are still classified because I've
reported on those and that speaks to the
space race and there is talk right now
with the current administration
excuse me of rebooting the space race I
think that is extraordinarily dangerous
for a number of reasons and I be first
and foremost because they're also
talking about perhaps a return to
nuclear testing that's frightening and
if you look at the weapons tests that
we're done in space you get a sense of
how dangerous this all can be Merlin
Ocean Ohio please go ahead with your
question or comment for any Jenkinson's
yeah this is mr. Jacobson and thanks for
having me and my grandfather's first
name was total horrible Jacobson that
was Leif Eriksson brother so I don't
know I thought I'd bring it up but
anyways the question I wanted to ask you
do they the government still have all
that material he picked up a long haul I
mean that in Roswell
Merlin Jacobson of Goshen Ohio 93 years
young thank you for watching amazing you
have it you have the adventure or spirit
in your blood as for the Roswell remains
we don't know where they are do we know
that there were remains we'll get you a
little bit more water sorry about that I
mean it depends who you ask about the
remains I write about that in area 51 I
think that's one of those mysteries and
maybe to your earlier caller if there
was a program that could be declassified
can you imagine if Roswell was really
Declassified Annie Jacobsen is the
author of four books her first came out
in 20
eleven area51 uncensored history of
America's top secret military base
Operation Paperclip came out in 2014 and
that was the secret intelligence program
that brought Nazi scientists to America
the Pentagon's brain an uncensored
history of DARPA
America's top-secret military research
agency came out in 2015 and her most
recent book is phenomena the secret
history of the US government's
investigations into extrasensory
perception and psychokinesis she tells
us that her next book will have
something to do with the CIA
that leaves it pretty broad I guess do
you enjoy the book tour I love it I love
getting out there on the road and
talking to people who like to read
reminds me of that image that we talked
about of Edgar Mitchell the man on the
moon reading you know and you think
about this idea the archetype of reading
of knowledge couldn't I often say I have
the best job in the world I mean I get
to write books and listen to what
readers think about and what the
experience of reading the books and then
how it influences them in their lives
and their thinking and their as they
become more of an alert and
knowledgeable part of the citizenry
let's hear from Barbara in Newark New
Jersey hi Barbara hi speaking about
near-death experiences and extrasensory
perception I had a near-death experience
and I think the brain is is more
powerful than any computer also have you
heard of dark social it's supposed to be
something where on the internet people
can read what you write on Facebook or
in any kind of blog or anything and then
they take it and they write it and claim
it as their own and then when you go to
their
your own writing you're being told that
you are be you're plagiarizing yourself
now hey Barbara before you you go you
talked about near-death experiences what
was yours
I fell on concrete slipped and hit the
back of my head on concrete and I had no
nothing to prevent my whole weight
hitting just on the back of my head and
I was out for I don't know how long but
when I got in the ambulance I saw and I
don't know whether it was vertigo or
what it was but it was like a jet
speeded up rocketship speed like a in
front of my eyes
but it was it was going from left to
right or right to left and it it was
like a what would you call it a like a
slot machine going in front of my eyes
alright I apologize we're almost at
attack near-death experiences were they
have those been investigated as well
yes I mean I write about them in the
book phenomena because that's that
conversion moment for a lot of people
where they have a near-death experience
and they come back from that with
extreme conviction about what they are
now going to pursue and it often has as
the caller explained to do with
consciousness you know what is the brain
capable of because if you go somewhere
else come back you have certainly have a
different perspective and I find that
super interesting medical research
involved in a lot of the things that
you've looked at yeah absolutely human
physiology I mean that's where we are
today with the ESP programs instead of
the parapsychologist you have
neurobiologist neurophysiologists
looking inside the brain and inside the
ball but the body and working to map the
human brain is it
particularly when you put the military
in the mix because the military is
working to enhance human functioning
enhance cognition and ultimately to
weaponize these systems are there
civilian applications like all things
there are as dual use for the last three
hours Annie Jacobson has been our guest
on booked eveything